on salue seb bienvenue à tous salut les
gars c'est bon on est parti pour ce
premier speech s féminin de l'histoire
des speechs s ouais c'est la création
c'est carrément la classe avec avec
m'écoute des joueuses qui jouent bien
aux échecs qui sont assez mignonne ce
dont parlait avant un point de saab mais
on disait on disait katia way du coup
pas d mais bon quand même selon les gens
même seulement le ou non mais si sylvain
donc on était très heureux de ça et donc
bon tu es aussi heureux du du niveau
quoi oui maïs et elle joue bien elles
sont mignonnes c'est génial très bien
parfait c'est fantastique et quartiers
en plus championne du monde web lice
exact bon mais quand même internet c'est
très différent je suis d'accord avec toi
mais bon ça veut dire qu'il ya du lait
veulent pas on démarre bas avec de bons
toute façon je pense qu'on va voir sa
très solide
telle est prononcée alors à temps est-ce
que ça commençait d'ailleurs les parties
non non on le voit l'image mais on les
voit l'image en train de discuter je
pense qu'elles font
non il faut par une conférence call je
sais pas en tout cas les deux joueuses
c'est des joueuses quand même assez
comment dire qu'une belle longévité déjà
sur le circuit puisque danielian elle a
40 ans et on est international depuis un
petit moment déjà et au moins une
quinzaine d'années qu'on la voit dans
les championnats d'europe et à peut-être
avec une petite baisse d'activité
dernièrement mais ça reste une
excellente chose autour de 2400 à l'eau
en 2003 qu'il ya 2400 et l'amener au
bond m'a bien sûr super connus qui
jouera les candidats d'ailleurs féminin
la nasa démarre la semaine prochaine je
crois je savais même pas qu'elle me tue
la faune et puis ben oui probablement la
grande favorite quand même parce qu'il
ya 150 points que son vélo et puis à mon
avis quand même plus active et plus au
fait des des choses quoi actuelle un peu
hâlé il ya quand même y'a pavlov
derrière faria une ombre mais ben
justement est ce que le fait qu'il est
candidat la semaine prochaine ça veut
pas dire d'éviter un peu les les prépas
justement monsieur foot non oui mes
joueurs n'ont pas à ce qu'elle va jouer
elle va elle va pas forcément jouer ces
ouvertures pas du tout mais c'est un
dauphin je pense qu'elles ont suffi ce
très bon niveau pour pouvoir être
honnête tu peux même préparé des trucs
spécialement spécifiquement ce format là
je pense que je suis sûr que l'agglo
pour enfin je le sais juste elles se
valent se servir de cette de cet
événement pour ce pour se préparer pour
les candidats en fait il nous est
possible mais ça vient de commencer
ouais vlad ils étaient très contents de
dudu du calendrier parce qu'il disait
que alors attends moi j'ai pourraient
pourquoi je peux pas suivre et katia on
se doit une quinzaine de cavaliers
attend alors toi ça s'avère que toi tu
vois et en fait on est on est tous à ne
pas voir maintenant je vais faire
arisman avait un petit et que je vais
vraiment une partie qui se joue entre
mais il doit y doit y avoir un bug c'est
sûr ouais ça y est ça y est je peux la
chope et c'est bon ça va s'ouvrir
ouais c'est une carreaux cannes et les
positions très solide pour les mains
garde-fous pour les blancs mais bon pas
encore eu de grosse activité de la peur
de fou mais bon tout petit petit point
important j 7 avant de se plonger dans
la partie c'est de voir les lots sur de
chasse comme parce qu'en fait l'aller
lokon a scellé l'homicide les loups
ouais du coup ça permet de voir que sur
internet vu qu'on se pose un peu là
question les lots sont
pas si éloigné pas s'éloigner on dirait
quand même a priori on dirait avantages
de la knu mais avec une réserve fois on
n'a pas vraiment les gorée de données
sur internet
du coup et çà çà çà çà ressasser ça peut
être un match très serré puis en plus
c'est la bulle est bon c'est pas trop
non plus le niveau des joueuses en vue
des moeurs ok bon bah c'est une position
assez classique dans les noirs vont
essayer de activer le fou comme elles
veulent faire là et si possible
l'échangé contre l'autre je pense j'ai
toujours dû enfin je joue beaucoup ses
positions avec avec les noirs seb
puisque j'ai joué les scandinaves
d'écart au cannet tout ça et j'ai jamais
aimé jouer ces trucs là avec les noirs
parce que tu as l'impression que tu vas
mal pour le gain dans quoi ouais tu veux
pas pour le gard enfin bon je pense que
dans ses formes à la tuque je vais à peu
près tout ce que tu veux tu ailles a
toujours donné une connerie quoi mais
bon là quand même c'est vrai que le
petit fou des cats là les deux fous qui
matin que le roi le côté c'est non mais
en plus tu vas toujours retenu pour les
avec les blancs parce que même si un
jour tu échanges les dames donc l'avons
tu peux jouer à la taxe sur les droits
lgbt ont déjà gelé comme je pense oui tu
échanges les dames tu as encore la
majorité de pions en fait c'est un
avantage qui peut durer durer durer
durer et durer
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer comme
kessous où je ferai comme toi je change
changerait les fous de cases noires
voilà les russes c'est ce qui alarme les
[ __ ] que d'un fou et de tours et la
dame qu'elle condamne tout c'est
peut-être le truc rêver ouais mais ça tu
l'obtiendra jamais on va boire ou alors
faut réussir à pousser 25 et ouais bah
c'est peut-être qu'elle voulait faire
d'ailleurs avec tour des 5 mais
finalement est-ce que c'était un si bon
parce qu'elle va s'enflammer je le tour
j'ai simplement tanger et 5 c à leur
show wes à la tête d'un mauvais coup
mais ça la met un coup tu peux faire tu
vois un peu en parce que t'as pas envie
de passer le premier match aussi la
première partie a peut-être envie de
s'envoyer en l'air tout de suite ouais
si tu craques si tu craques pages conçu
fait juste tour 17 et tabarre compte par
exemple tu peux pas faire tourner son
parce qu'il faut prendre 6
c'est pas mal ça ouais signe un tour
d'essai de tête pour préparer le
doublage elle a acheté chine attendait
sa part être le coup elle se met à mal
autant en tout cas c'est bon ça va c'est
pas ça il ya dur vous non
c'est une seconde seulement hier
alcantara il est tombé il est tombé il
est tombé d'ailleurs ouais non mais une
seconde mais tour des 7 je vois pas
pourquoi elle ne sais quoi qui
l'embêtent sur tours 17
je sais bien la peur france
non mais faut cinq noms vous les
combinés l'idée de fossiles alors
version du petit et le plus sec
c'est fou et cinq attaques la dame qui
doit rester c'est au compteur y'a pas de
dames c'est sur m6 où les sacrés crimée
tour des huit il y avait peut-être cinq
ans pour ses huit local attac le fou
d'une tumeur ou des tur parent dépendant
hélas pas le temps de mettre un cavalier
pour aller au f4 j'ai l'impression que
parce qu'elle va se prendre trucs sur le
roc ces dames envie de valider 5-4 si tu
touches à kadhafi attaquent le car ils y
étaient contentes égalise complètement
là mais j'ai peur de g7 qui sont
complètement
il sent un peu songeur après si ça si ça
marche ça marche mais je le fais tu fais
qu'un rallye des cinq n'est pas une
connerie en avait quatre fois f6 je suis
tout seul ouais mais peut-être et du
coup au moins j'ai change je fais ce
qu'on voulait faire tout à l'heure j'ai
changé un fouquet non mais par contre je
fais fouet sans compétition qu'avec deux
semaines et surtout des six je ne sais
pas mais je prends 26 jeunes
ah ben oui je sais pas mais bon ça
semble quand même pas mal de tenir les
fous comme ça comme un seul homme gardez
le le point de mire sur g7 et achète à
la fête d'arras cinq fours b1 et geci
g6 ça sent ça sent pas la sérénité pour
pour les noirs en plus si tu peux même
un jour jouer dames le 3 mai qui des
fous prend à cette équipe euros des gens
quand tu veux tu approcher 2 h 6 ses
positions position d'ici là jamais
réussi à égaliser dans cette partie
danielian non non c'est ce qu'on disait
quoi pour le petit plus
bon là ça c'est mal embarqué comme
facile landes comme ça pendant tout le
match ça va être compliqué la b6
je pense à le battre
la dame ok bon peut-être d'alger selon
cette dame bessette
je sais pas mais après tu as tu fait à
manger sain qui est des cinq joue
cavalier avec 4 contres à fond quoi tu
les monts il faut faire ça je pense m'en
façon takata 30 secondes comptent quatre
minutes kheddam des 5 mai à temps il n'y
a pas une
[Musique]
ok non je crois que sur fou prend f6 à
la le temps de faire d'un preuve 3 et je
vois pas de je vois pas de tactique
permettant de sauver le fouet de et
l'adapter à la fed à mettre 4 elle
menace ou prend même si c'est encore me
lève comme si ça peut même nous
imaginons menaces sont menace rien aux
menaces de menacer quoi bah oui c'est
bon mais ont menacé peut-être g4 quoi
bon aller c'était son que malcolm pas
beaucoup de temps mais bon avec la
fatigue et où elle pourra jamais faire
ça tout va et puis en plus c'est pas du
comme on disait il ya quelques minutes
c'est pas du 5 plus de cdu cinq plus un
rêve une grosse à la tu peux pas il a en
plus pourrait même le soin de les dom
mais là elle veut sûrement garder les
dames parce qu'il peut beaucoup de temps
et ouais alors tu fais quoi tes chansons
tu peux pas échanger les fous parce
qu'il ya tout reprendre et 2 way
du coup est ce qu'on peut faire ça pas
vraiment de sens de donner h
tamara qui a trait sur france 5 tu veux
te retrouves les ponts les tours 17 je
voulais faire mais bon tu défends de la
même si ce la fin alors qu'on me demande
d'un nouveau délai retenu alors attends
à main c'est à ça c'est c'est le truc
que j'ai pas réussi à faire ça m en
modérateur parce qu'un mec qui vient sur
ledit landen que je peux modéré regardez
du coup la danielian elle a obtenu selon
ce qu'on voulait qu'elle obtienne mais
juste bien mis le temps que met là elle
est pas mal en fait enfin clairement
c'est donc là on ne prend pas en d2
pascal bach point de l'adam et eve à
contrôler complètement la colonne donc
là il faut faire ce qu'elle fait de
petits coups qu'elle ait peut-être
prendre des tours des 8es elle le fait
bon après est-ce que la colonne des cils
important mais là ça c'est dommage parce
que tu préfères échanger pour fou on
sait que normalement c'est meilleur que
tour cavale et le flou domine très bien
le cavalier est 6e si en plus il ya des
pions des deux côtés normalement ça
favorise l'e juste la majorité
le fou qui contrôle la vitz production
éventuellement si on n'a pas ça va être
chaud ouais normal as-tu fait d'armes
français 7 je pense qu'elle va faire
dans le concept tranquille et après tu
fais bref un roi de rome iii pour
commencer et puis tu fout quoi de ton le
fond elle fera vraiment bien placé un
calcul et loire ou 5 quand même mais bon
tour des huit pas mal n'empêche que
renoir de je pense tu vas faire un truc
genre caravaneige qui a échangé par des
f 5 5 vite
oui oui ça va être le jeu normalement
ces avantages blanche à cause du fait
qu'il ya des pions des deux côtés du
kung fu que dit aller d'un côté à
l'autre
alors c'est pas le cas du cabinet web ou
des conceptions sur deux hells ici on
parle d'un point de vue à ce genre tu
vois tu mets ordinateur contre
ordinateur tu penses que c'est nul quand
même chanceux elle est ou pas nous c'est
ce qu'on apprend comme règle tu vois aux
théories que oui oui dans mes clés
clairement tu prends les blancs tous les
jours mais s imagine que je sais
alma 0 comme ça je dirais nu mais
j'aurais fait qu'il y ait bikers est à
sa place à valence et 7 pour faire une
muraille ah c'est pas idiot cependant à
5 sur mon aile rue du pont à singapour
qu'elle va prendre et roy cattrall fait
comme ça bon elle prend des coups et
l'adduction un pari du pion et à 84 m et
après elle va faire f 5 le cas c'est
bien je sue way avec les noirs elle
donne quand même une petite leçon pour
pour ceux qui suivent de comment gérer
ses positions
ce qu'on va faire attention quand même
tous les pions de l'est le roi sont sur
case blanche dit la couleur du four
jadot bloqué avec h 4 min kiev au calame
réussissent à avancer avec son roi l'a
peut-être faire 5 3 des 4 way et non
mais ça d'autres pouvant semer sa
compétence tenir son je pense qu'elle
est belle si c'est logique
la maraude sims ont donné soit voilà
bien je vais peut-être les garçons mais
on a quand même pas non parce que ça
peut faire brasser trois des quatre un
miracle cavaliers des visas sans
problème en fait c'est ce qu'elle a vu
elle va sacrifier sur b à huy elle va
s'axer sur b mais les trains p 5
mais est-ce que c'est pas perdre sa voix
son calme face à lorient joue là non
elle va tomber
incroyable à la elle a réfléchi à huy
alors quoi c'est pas perdre c'est parce
qu'on aurait peut-être pu forcer les
noirs affaires g5 à jouer à alger ouais
mais en fait non ça va je crois que ça
va parce que âge et ses pattes du coup
c'est dans le cas où il ya deux pions
pour le non ouais mais si tu rêverais je
sais pas parce que si tu veux forcer
j'ai ça veut dire qu'il faut que le roi
soit pathé et du privé g5 je peux pas
prendre
oui je comprends ce que tu veux vraiment
ce canton à un deuxième clip que là ça
marche donc là c'était bien elle pouvait
sacrifier ses tenues le fascine c'est ce
ce combat là têtus hindoue
dans les moments mais est-ce que ce soit
à la deuxième partie qui a commencé ou
pas bon ok donc c'est pas passé par bug
ouais parce que qu'ils avaient prouvé
sign on vous promet 5 oui tu as raison
en fait c'est nul dans tous les cas le
jour où tu es pathé et que tu fais tu
fais j'ai cinq âgés ce sera nul serait
ok dommage parce qu'elle avait bien
défendu
car non ok mais bon le une secondes par
coup c'est un peu
ouais un peu short toi mais on va pour
se mettre aussi malotaux les chocolats
plus vite mais bon elle a montré que l a
bien défendu well as bien elle a bien
défendu et intéressant d'un point de vue
pédagogique comment est là elle a réussi
à tenir et transformé parce que c'est
vrai que c'était la commune et des
bonnes idées assez rapidement et là bon
bah voilà je pense que c'est le genre de
truc qu'on va voir pendant le match et
qu'on voit en général dans m'explique
chez des petites ouvertures pas trop
jouer tranquille on sent les pièces et
on joue aux échecs en tout cas jusqu'en
jusqu'en demi-finale pour les masques
pour le pour le pour le speech as
masculins c'est souvent ça après c'est
vrai quand ils s'approchent du titre ça
commença à jouer un peu plus sérieux
ouais ouais ça commence à changer un peu
le genre de dépenses et 128 me paraît
pas exactement mais je retiens tu
t'accroches mélasse approche peu de mal
s'accroche par elle le fait qu'ils aient
b3 ce genre de position j'ai toujours
pensé que les noirs avaient complètement
égalisé qu'en tire prénom c5
mais ça veut dire que danielian elle
joue les structures de pions type slave
karo kann c'est un peu la même structure
joue blanc noir c'est cette structure
même tête un coup comme dam des quatre
j'aurais joué tu vas nous tapez tapez
tordent une découverte concernant
bondouy depuis sept ans le bail pourrait
dire jouer cavalier ou 4 monde naturel a
apris prise il ya une limite c'est 7 ou
des chiche je peux prendre aussi un peu
de retenue d'eau au fond et prendre un
grand changement de ctu fait nul
a ok bon tu voulais prendre 2 e
j'ai peint d'une culotte pour la taille
des minorités en plus inexistantes
peut-être un art qui aurait pu prendre
deux maîtres lecavalier en d3 ou
pourquoi pas l'argent on est foutu la
dame en h4 personne ne veut bon après
voilà elle joue plus vite
la position est plus facile aussi que la
précédente dans la partie précédente
avec les noirs c'était tellement dur de
jouer bah oui et non parce que tape
quand même avoir l'habitude de ce genre
de post enfin c'est le truc je pense que
quand tu joues ce genre de structure ces
semi automatique oui c'est vrai que là
la première alerte est peut-être un peu
lente après peut-être un peu le stress
le temps de se mettre dans la compét
mais j'aime bien cette tâche quatre ans
fait toujours l'impression que c'est
sympa tu me tues mais un peu la pression
sur le cavalier le pion recettes
ouais après dans les faits puis pas
parce que si je bouge pas les deux le
cavalier le fou auquel adam date obligé
d'une police mon coeur et mon sort et
j'aurais fait tourbe et de honnêtement
mais un tour des deux parrains combien
samara meutrier tour des douilles et
paquette a maintenant je prends des deux
hommes non la tournée au caire est
peut-être bon jeu 3-3 et je tombais 200
cochons
c'est peut-être ce n'était pas faisable
mais juste si tu obligé de jouer comme
ça c'est un peu triste
ouais c'est commencer pour ces quatre
réponses a bien joué qu'elle a peut-être
fait retour des cadres 4 mai tours
concept france à tours b cup ce week-end
des 3 et puis on prend cette fois je me
suis trop et on protège mais peu importe
d'un match 3 dommage
ouais achetant que j'aimais aussi que
met un truc angers cat et bloquer quoi
mettre la dame un peu hors jeu peut-être
y aller pour cavaliers 5 maintenant
chasser la tour où tourner
c'est mal c'est mal organisé
ouais à la caisse à lesparre à
l'organiser maintenant est ce que tu vas
pas l'échangé ont réussi se mettre en
cavale est en déclin
tu peux après le problème c'est que un
jour elle se jouera au sein qui veut 5e
des séries 4
mais qui sait ce n'est pas évident de
jouer ses positions face caen fait là
avec les blancs talent et noir qu'est ce
que je veux dire j'ai rangé mes
résultats avec les noirs et et cantal et
noir visuellement c'est moins d'ego
qu'est ce que je veux dire
quant à elle et blanc et que tu joues
semaine fils sans mal alors que cantal
et noir tu sais ce que tu veux qu'elle a
peut-être avec adam être capable
d'amasser 2 tu penses ben là c'est
presque tour de ce nom
ouais mais tu fais d'un rêve 5 après tu
repars hockey en tout cas tu tues créé
l'incertitude tu mets la pression du
monastère camaïeu quatre là j'ai pas mes
[Musique]
nombreux peut-être lafuste vous prendre
cette mémoire et l'incertitude
ok donc les parties pour ce déséquilibre
il va y avoir la mèche 5
ouais et là bas il faut encore arriver
et changer les tours mais c'est
compliqué 2 tu dois jusqu'à 10 du coût
ou et cap tupou v jupe tout je pense
qu'en réalité c'est juste égal comme
position suppose ibnou ces visuels je
pense l'avantagé des noirs mais eux mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu pénible pour
pour danielian deux parties ça fait deux
fois qu'elle souffrait un peu c'est
pénible et en plus ça tu tu as du mal à
s'organiser pour les tours parce que la
tourbe et emprises toujours peut-être qu
est ce qu elle doit proposer d'échanger
dames avec dan des trois bonnes
questions
un peu comme tout à l'heure plus que ça
a plutôt bien marché
france 3 a faibli les cases noires dont
elle souffre est d'éviter les matins
six malaisiens avec les blancs elle va
juste attendre après la bosse qui
arrivait avec les noirs que tu peux être
un plomb dans ses positions l'aï
mentionné mais parce que c'est tellement
solide de côté blanc j'ai demandé à
l'escale à l'escale est pas en train de
bouger le cavalier vers détroit voire
même f4 pour venir un petit peu attaqué
par omar qu'elle attaquera pas grand
chose en tout cas elle tient la case b4
était en b2c toute façon c'est la bonne
cause en d3 pour le cab et les comptes
chèques de minorités sinon c'est aller
contre la case b4 c'est hyper important
ouais bon elle peut attendre elle peut
aussi essayer de jouer pour g4 comprend
puis on prend alors que la dame est un
petit peu de côté attention pour ses
quatrièmes mais tu que je pour ces
quatre ces chemins canon pénible jusqu'à
+ b3 et appelé à tour en btf que tu sais
pas mais je sors tu voulais faire quoi
pardon gt coupé de lescott mais
peut-être jessen son prix est là il n'y
a pas un intermédiaire ya rien n ya rien
à débourser 4 c'était bien joué à tomber
an mal an
c'est bien joué menace b3 menace b3
après tu peux tu peux peut-être sacrifie
la qualité numérique soit y
je pars position positions complexes sem
ouais tu m'entends tu jettes aurait un
coût de la connexion
ouais je tente en chantant donc cavalier
e 2 et pourquoi tant j'ai du coup je me
suis dit pourquoi ce qu'avait b3 elle a
fait tomber en provenace et b3 et
maintenant elle force les changes des
damer le pion g4 reste indépendamment
elle va bloquer le attend tout reprend
1,5 3f deux tours us to run qui est des
cut
je me lasse b5 et c6 et tu vas jusqu'à
6-6 enfermement carrément très bien je
quitte ours et 8 plus ou moins force ou
alors tu lâches lac à loches et tu joues
avec qualité de moi mon jeu gagnera
jamais son nom mais tête avec les norias
faire nul en lâche pas la calloc'h et la
tour qui ressort à elle peut pas faire
tourcoing f5 si les idées 6 beaucoup
petite faiblesse la lecavalier handicap
très bien et il faut probablement
changer une tour quand même pour les
blancs je pense je sais pas qui est
mieux ici qu'ailleurs mais attend on ne
peut pas prendre des jetons j'ai eu ma
chance à f 4k améliorer assez bien pas
mal pas maintenant franchement je trouve
que c'est bien ce qu'elle fait et elle a
réglé son problème de temps direct donc
c'était peut-être juste kouadio stress
vois aucune menace fouet trois échecs
quand même ok c'est chaud là
kyle croxall c'est possible ça va bien 5
à kiel et surtout quand on prend 8
et ouais ça semble gagner un pion sanon
feeling parce que tu donc épouse sont
battus vasque épreuve 6 intermédiaire
quel profit ce droit à cette ag 3 ok je
vais montrer parce que c'est joli
je séchais croit h7
pour preuve un g3 tchèque ouais c'est
joli et suroît et enfin les deux échecs
3f deux tours prend un droit prend et
géant dames quelle façon c'est la seule
chance pour les noirs bah je joue au pop
doute chose ok - rue ok mais là ya roger
catez ce qu'ils ont mangé galcon -5 et
en plus c'est lui voilà mon avis c'est
quoi que il ya sept ans n'a qu'un corner
ouais encore poussé 1 et encore des
trucs non qu'avec les blancs tu mousse
qui ait eu à leur demander si tu es qui
a aidé cathala faire pousser un way qui
étaient 4 pouces c'est quelque chose
qu'il sait si ce point se forge par
james on n'en perdent c'est sur mais bon
tu veux gagner je pense que quand même
oui mais sinon bekkat mont des cats pas
mal c'est joué d'ailleurs prise b4 on
apprend b4 apprend b4 et surtout b2 au
pire tu auras cavale yeux de voix mais
ces hommes hockey à quatre c'est bien
joué donc à bessines je pense ou besson
tc2 ce que tu couvres tu couvre toute la
colonne là c'est pas mal on as comprends
et je dis bon elle veut prendre la carte
du coup bien jeu et du coup le pion le
pion décathlon contrôlée par le cavalier
dur à pousser la roue ou trois imagine
ces droits se rapproche mais 3 3 il ya
peut-être il y avait des quatre et je
prenais des sacs noirs mais c'est quand
même le final besoin oui la tête à deux
tours avec les pneus en plus petit laps
de temps et bah écoute
moi je pense que ces annonces un petit
match sympa en fait ouais parce que
finalement les scénarios des deux
parties se ressemblent à cno qui a une
position en tout cas visuellement
avantageuse et danielian qui défend bien
et ouais là elle passe à la française
bonjour un peu le même genre de soutien
mais inc et qui remarque que ça fait
deux fois qu'elle domine dans les
finales cavaliers contre x dans la
première elle avait raté à la fin là nul
mais elle avait quand même bien tenu et
là dans la deuxième une nouvelle fois
avec le cavalier est là elle manoeuvre
bien il ya s'appuie elle fait que de
toute façon ces dépositions sastaro dans
tactik et puis d'un coup tu es avec le
temps c'est compliqué mais bon c'est
assez bien je trouve qu'elle a été
extrêmement réactif quand même au niveau
du temps je le répète n'est pas ça
pouvait juste être un match super chiant
quand elle perd tous les matchs où les
partis autant filtrage y est
moi je suis content j'ai envie de voir
j'ai envie de voir un match et qui est
bon ouais puis c'est rassurant pour le
bullet aussi bas non ça tu sais pas non
tu te dis vu qu'elle est capable d'être
rapide tu sais jamais trop à l'avancé
mais quand même les mecs
les tortues tu sens que tu sens que
c'est pas des tortues ninja quoi donc dû
te dis bon alors là ya pas de jussac et
prend b3 elle pourra reprendre le pion
c5 parce qu'il y aura un cloître
d'accord et je connaissais pas je
m'étais dit que je suis super bien mais
on sait pas ce qu'elle pourra faire qui
les prend ses 5 et peut-être taper le
fou des trois jeunes est encore une fois
une histoire de père de foucauld vd elle
assure que les français sachent ce site
est sûre qu'elle allait prendre
possession de leur statut mais engage 3d
x prime à la casse très vite du coup à
george aurait fait faux f5 quasi tempo
alès le fou auquel osm mais il ya pire
il ya pions destin qu'on fait on peut
isoler petit change de pièce
ouais pourra combler plus en plus le
pirée en plus l'ailé noire aucune
activité quasiment il n'y a pas à vis
pas vraiment de menaces lesquels sont
pas en place et donc elle prend pas
l'fou cavalier seul
j'aurais quand même été tenté de le
sauver ce soit à terme
mais bon d'un autre côté la case de 4 ça
peut être pénible c'est à écailles qui
sera vaine dessus donc on va pas quand
même on m'a dit de prendre le foot après
suez qui prend tout reprend camaïeu 4
ira cavailles f5 très rapidement et très
concrètement tu dois pas avoir le temps
en fait non mais je faire cavalier c'est
le cas tout de suite à qui c'est quatre
ça c'est peut-être bien jouer comme ça
j'ai toujours l'autre cagoulés qui tient
des cinq étudiants 1,4 voilà je suis dit
bon gré le temps mais va se prendre un
café leffe 5 fu des cats avoir commencé
comme color bon sauf que là c'est un
vrai avantage
alors est ce qu'on prend
il ya deux ans l'air assez dur en l'air
ouais mais sur dame france et deux sur
quatre ans ces deux peut-être un coup
comme food et 4 ou prises sept étrangers
cinq reprises de sa tétine et son doudou
un petit peu de compensation mais moi je
serai le noir j'irai si y'a pas un truc
qui s'imaginent que je rêve ils font en
d4 un père soit parce que je me serais
dit que je me tète un peu du jeu c'est
pas aujourd'hui qui a ébranlé cette
trucs comme ça
mais oui clairement je pense que tu dois
y aller parce que si tu avais pas ça tu
étais juste et justement mais en fait tu
fous des cas de ces chinois bright food
et qu'à ses charmes tête tu fais tu peux
faire d'annoncé 600 à vue les relances
bref j'ai l'impression qu'à elle veut
bien calculé variantes
bon après c'est un moment critique ici
bon c'est normal de prendre le temps
ouais non compliquées comme position
mais bon si tu prends pas assez de elle
va faire ses trois tours d un elle va de
visser sur le pion des cinq est d'accord
enfin c'est quand même le cas de figure
où tu as quand même le mauvais matériel
les pièces blanches sont super bien
placé de blaze tu vois c'est pas le truc
de rêve quoi après et puis c'est vrai ça
se feront alors là je te dire c'est un
coup qu'avec auquel je reste que
j'aurais même pas envisagées pour fuir
la vérité m le fou et 6 ont fait manquer
food et 4 ces genres très logique et
surtout f6 tu veux que cavalier 6,6 à
wabush secondes peut-être juste uv
change arrive si ces jouets c3 et jouer
la position bêtement mais en fait j
ouais tu peux faire ça tu peux mettre
une dame angers 4 le toto un bon rapport
matériel à un d'am dam de tours
cavaliers contam de sourds cavaliers
dans le pur isolé normalement ça se
gagne
mais après faut encore la ja jeudi que
le cavaly c'est cool pour la défonce
fond tu peux regarder nous parce que il
ya les histoires de tous âges
tu peux regarder la partie de quatre
chefs mazet donc qu'un exemple mais pas
reconnue que par vlad en fait c'est un
exemple reconnu par par ses pairs c'est
une partie je pense qu'il a joué mais là
je me dis que en fait sur ces trois le
problème c'est peut-être à 5
et du coup elle te fragilise le pion b
3e et peut-être qu'un jour d'un v6 sera
pénible bons à cinq tués aouidat choro q
tu veux pas jouer à quatre voitures non
j'ai collé à 5 pour pour jouer sur le
pion b3 quoi stocker ou là ça c'est très
dangereux car il y eu trois paraît fort
n'a personne à troyes et tours d or d
arrêt ouais qu'est ce que tu aimes poule
sur le cavalier là honnêtement je suis
pas trop le plan de l'otan dans l'est
dans les structures de type karo kann ce
label m'a assez impressionné je dois
dire que tu ne peux pas elle peut pas
prendre l'option via le mode du couloir
donc tu as peut-être le temps de waimes
et même si tu doutes tu vas prendre le
tour des quatre c4
oui c'est ça ce sont les batman va
peut-être la tour en d2 la d'amendé
1 et c'est ce qui va se passer mais h3
bien jeunes en mal
du coup le doom et en raison du retour
des quatre c4 sur le cloud mais pour
l'instant rien mis en relief si c'est
encore mais bon non mais tu fais tour
des quatre tours d2 en d1
elle fera dan dah tu triple en fait va
peut-être c'est avec les noms après le
petit roy y fit trois sets séjour ouais
je suis belle va faire tourner tout le
droit nous tourner trois répond
passeront pas secondaire veilleux 4
parce que je vois pas comment il peut
sous parce que parfois tu as aussi
l'idée de switcher avec tours h4 ou quoi
pour jouer le roi mais je vois pas je
vois pas cette idée là arriver dans
cette position autour des trois dames d
un c4 ça paraît logique mais bon quand
bien même tu gagnes le pion des 5 s'est
pas fait encore après oui bien sûr bien
sûr parce que tu devrais apprendre avec
un pion on est alors elle focalise pas
mal ça en fait tu élimines le cavalier
pour faire le truc quand on new as well
as l'homme détroit et ses labels gagné
en force bon après il y aura dames 6 ok
mais oui il y aura de toute façon c 4
enfin peut-être
la dame en d2 comme ça il n'y a pas de
dépenses et katakana mais je pense ouais
voilà lé patron qu'il en fait en plus
elle aura peut-être des options deuxième
faiblesse avec h6 leur tour h1 que tu
mets la dame en d2 ah ouais tu peux
faire est tu peut switcher la torah est
maintenant en plus l'autre à la fée p 6
enfin peut-être elle peut y perdre du
dam p5 aussi s'il peut être intéressant
parfois mais bon la c4 spa bompas
confond avec le petit monde autochtone
alors là a été à quatre ce qu'elle veut
faire parvenir votre bien et tu fais
d'amd de même de 2 auquel on doit le
faire b5
mais les cinq dames détroit le 5b
troisième wimbée 5 b3 et auquel à y
aller tout rachat qui rôdent dont tu
parlais aussi à tout moment
bah dramatique quand même des tours
aussi qu'ils auraient auquel voilà il
faut qu'elle essaie de contrer quelque
part si elle peut laver l'idée c'est
qu'il y avait sur président de quatre
échecs adam tragique mais là ça pue un
peu après à la deuxième école c'est de
laisser prendre le pion il met une tour
en dix-sept le vélo caire non ça sort
alors un terrible menace comme tourcoing
f2 ouais on échange on s'est tous webcup
vous tous rêvent 4 direct j'ai pas
lequel est le plus ouais non parce qu'il
y aura la cité sur les confettis la
créature à tour prendre b2 des attardés
6 oui oui c'est ça je me rends dans le
pion mais avancer de six attend
peut-être si tu prends prend tour f4
alphée tour des six francomtois fut au
tour des citoyens au québec à la toux je
t'attends qui n'ont plus de toit
mais en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il
faut jouer avec le noir absolument un
moment donné s'activer quoi parce que
marcher dessus après c'est pas toujours
simple à gagner 1 ces finales deux tours
avec un prénom plus qui est bloquée
comme ça ouais bah c'est bien vu ok la
tombée de marche pas parce qu'on y va à
je sais pas si c'est bien joué en fait à
madrid et maintenant sur des 6 3 8
points 17 year award et 8 et le con tu
sais pas tu mêleront des 6es à lui rêve
2 qui n'est pas très bien placé h57 bien
joué mais elle a plus de temps par
contre 9 secondes mais je pense qu'elle
a elle n'a objectivement ça m'étonnerait
que les blancs soient mieux en réalité
je pensais même égale aussi tu mêleront
quand même en cette fois où on sait que
tu vas c4 besson mais tu as quand même
lui qui m'a chargé m je vois pas dans
quel monde ce que talent tu rêves tu as
les pions f aussi qui tombent facilement
ah oui c'est vrai il ya du talent et
pion f qui sont mal mais si tu prends et
que tu fais trois points du match 4
ouais je suis sûr wager quatre tours
prend je prends f2 qui mais tu peux
faire rager 2 h 3 peut-être pourquoi h3
roi prend des 5 es ok tête a plus aucun
avant
j'avais tellement j'allais dire est ce
qu on sent l'expérience de notre
quarantenaire mais bon l'autre une
expérience terrible si tu n'es pas sûr
qu'elle est tellement d'expérience elle
défend super bien un dernier choix des
fonds trusts vraiment très bien en
défense je pense qu'avec les blancs faut
déjà à prendre là nul en fait ben j'ai
l'impression aussi et je passerais tu
ton pion de plus c'est le pion m
bon ok je pense que sans elle de tenter
un petit becquet retour ces deux tours
ce front ouais j'ai l'impression tenace
et palin rock et blaya elle y va pour
gagner
tb cadbury qui protège f3 mais en fait
rouages que tu t'en fous il ya tour h2k
va faire tout rage autour ces deux
j'imagine mal oui voilà pour ces deux là
n'ont rien tour savez peut-être tour des
quatre tours des 4 ok ok donc ça ok elle
y va ça c'est bien bon ces changements
mais là ils sont quelques-uns à
l'automne ok ça va être intéressant à
voir mais c'est moins que les 2 va jouer
pour gagner un match il faut sept
secondes sur les autres
bah c'est bien parce que là non plus pas
tout le monde après un petit cours sur
le cas isolé ouais finalement finalement
lac dont elle a voulu être trop trop
propre peut-être tu vois ouais mais il y
avait moyen de peut-être plus pour
franck en fait peut-être fallu envoyer
ses quatre plus tôt tu voyais attendre
un peu moins non mais tu dois peut-être
arrivé a pas laissé la dame est rentrée
en e2 rsa c'est une banque qui sont ski
réputée très bonne pour le mans ça c'est
très bon c'est pour ça que je veux plus
jouer la propose quelques fous
progressiste parce que ça m'embête et je
préfère jouer au caïd et demain c'est
pas bien qu'il nous démontre la très bon
tout est relatif il ya bien un disant
ouais c'est très logique en fait une
arène un pion vers le centre le plus
j'ai entendu plongée tu veux jouer pour
eux cinq jours mais ok ce canevas et que
j'étais là je tranquille aussi ça oui
jean louis pion charmant il joue aussi
celui plus tard 5
il échange tu peux changer au centre
tous les échanges depuis on sent que ça
va voir la pause mais pour la peine
cette position là avec ses 4 c'est la
bonne variante pour les blancs si tu
veux pas à se retrouver moins bien alors
on demande pourquoi le score s'affiche
pas alors il s'affiche il affiché à côté
du nom des joueurs jong est ici donc le
score c'est un ennemi un ennemi pour le
moyen égalité en revanche non il ya le
chrono
alors par contre j'ai l'image qui a
frisé ça mais en fait c'est les gammes
chez elle qui frise mais sont libres et
non non non j'ai un truc c'est moi qui
est en fait je récupère leur cas mais
c'est mon écran qui a frisé et je m'en
suis pas rendu compte
et donc il reste 51 minutes de jeu pour
le cette phase là on sent même chose
l'an 5 + 1 après avoir peu de moi tu
passes contre + moi médecin et un plus à
rennes exactement
mais c'est pas une rumeur aussi c'est
une lourde et 1h30
1h30 ok c'est fait pour pour avoir à peu
près le même nombre de points 2 passes
et les cadences mais d'en pratiquer si
tu es si tu tombes sur des bons joueurs
de bullet les bullet son long parce que
ça envoie
messi est un mec qui est vraiment
derrière en bullet il peut se faire
enchaîner avoir bien peu savent le
fameux la fameuse stratégie de laisser
tourner un coup le bullet parce que tu
as de la vence ouais suivant les matchs
les bullet perd plus plus ou moins deux
parties peut y avoir une grosse
différence sur les physionomie de match
sur le nombre de parties dans la
dernière can ans donc ça va refaire un
pion isolé et
mais elle n'est pas si ma elle connaît
avec les blancs c'est sûr parce qu'elle
a joué la bonne variante et j'ai
l'impression qu'avec les noirs elle ne
connaît pas exactement où elle se
rappelle plus voilà l'enjeu lors des 5es
que l'on nous devrons au centre pas si
évident on tue aussi gros que j'imagine
directement mais surtout des sacs à
peut-être dès bahreïn direct ce qu'il
fallait prononcé quatre tout de suite le
bas tandis que le sous développement
je me rappelle plus la théorie pour te
dire la vérité mais je sais que les mecs
qui connaissent avec les blancs peuvent
être semi dangereux cependant si les
noirs connaissent si à rien c mais il
faut quand même connaître et là mais
katia qui est quand même pas en super
forme parce que les positions elle est
émue elle s'est quand même laissé
retournez donc bon bien joué de la part
de dn ayant évidemment mais mais katia
qui tu vois ça peut se payer des choses
comme ça quand même dans des matchs
serrés nous inquiète parce que ses
positions avec avantage surtout la
dernière en fait le plus haut idéal et
là elle a quand même pour une joueuse de
son calibre on attend à ce qu elle la
gagne quand même mal gré mal gré mal gré
la belle défense et malgré tout un jeu
bien sûr mais en fait elle va faire
cavalier seul
probablement pour gagner le temps qui
m'est donc fou détroit j'imagine est ce
que tu voulais prendre les cieux as tu
peux peut-être prendre je crois pas non
tu peux pas c'est toi tu retires ok
peut-être ça va ok tu peux avoir un plan
sciences et cava lieu 2 kg trois
cavaliers h5 ce que en réalité tu t'en
fiches qu'elle te prends tu t'en fiches
jeu par contre le pion dessin tout de
suite si ce fait on prend des cinq qui
avait lieu de fin qui a eu depuis on
prend des cinq cavaliers 4 je pense pas
que ceux qui ont des 5 soit un souci
majeur cas j'aurais vraiment fait
cavalier de père soit là mais tu laisses
de son mari tu la t5 et tuent par thomas
kaiser club
le truc c'est pour qui on demande on
éprouve qui bat mois plus tôt à en
changer pour les mêmes 1 pour 4 et a
plutôt bas franchement j'ai un peu
évolué n'ont pas évolué bah parce que
parce que en fait dans mes
oui déjà déjà avec l'esprit de
contradiction stade et en plus cela le
montre un peu du style quoi donc
ah non ça ça me montrez moi j'aime bien
l'idée de la torre que je vérifie à quel
point elle est active ou pas mais tu as
bien l'idée de la joueuse un peu ouais
tu j'aime bien une petite poussette je
comprends alors là en plus haletante une
idée qui peut être pas mal c'est que si
jamais la tour en h4 elle va menacer des
quatre regarde le car il ya plus de
cases
je m'étais posé la question dit alors
est-ce que tu pouvais jouer s'axer sur
lui et ça ne l'est pas mais là c'est
plutôt malin elle est vraiment tenir là
c'est chaud en guenon j'ai l'impression
que les noirs sont vraiment mal parce
que le pion des deux prend des saints
qui pourra vraiment jamais de jouer tu
va détruire la structure est vu ton roi
ça paraît complètement impossible donc
ouais tu dois vivre avec le pion en d5
et t25 hall où tu joues et 5 mai la
prime déjà déjà opté pour le moment ya
pas d c'est contré 1 mais ne voit pas
maria forcément quelque chose
épuisant +9 à long terme ont cet homme
là t'es juste ai juste marre ils
pouvaient pas tu peux te rend un jour
ainsi un carré ie7 avec des pour preuve
cet échec enfin on ne sait pas comment
exactement mais
après si ça tient ça tient mais tel quel
mais moi j'aimerais pas du tout alors
cailloux 7000 entreprises parlement on
peut pas vrai mais mais mais mais mais
comment comment on fait ça que tu fais
pas juste tranquille le fou à faire
fouet six cavaliers ces quatre là faut
trouver un coup très précis pour les
malades relève le cavaly l'album bad
cardiaque
c'est pas si évident mais ça me paraît
tellement probable que après qu'à tokyo
menace bep cap donc mais des 5 alors
comme meilleur et b4 - foulée 5 avec le
cap c'est pas mal parce que tu te
diriges de la structure des fonds ont
des trois ou quatre menaces bk toute
façon si tu fais qu'un voyage 5 ça fait
tout de suite mal parce que le fou g7
quand il se fait taper c'est tout de
suite un problème est d'alger 5 après
qu'ils rentrent ya tout qui rentrent et
étrangers 7 et d'un match 6 donc il y
avait le h5 c'est une vraie menace que
j'estime que vers la chine comme je sens
que si tu te bats mettre là d'un poteau
oui oui ça petit à deux coups laquelle
chaque dame g5 seimat imparable angers7
vous avez envie de jouer tant mieux car
ici que pour te dis tiens vraiment à 5
et à une impression que juge le pont les
cavaliers h5 déjà même cavalier une pour
120 kg 6 d'ailleurs découvert nous parce
que moi non non c'est pas mieux du coup
tu t'es sur qui va avoir d'autres
trompeuse qui lobe ouais c'est pas le
problème pour katia c'est que si elle se
rappelle plus de la théorie dans ce truc
là ça peut ça peut vite très pénible
faut être faut être précis avec les
noirs si tu te rappelle plus comment
jouer contre cette vente avec ses 4 ça
peut vite mal tourner ok vous bessin
qu'elle en avait dit p4 a tant besoin
que pouvait pas prendre à 5
mais il ya un problème de clouage elle
pouvait prendre
c'est impossible mais bombay 4 à l'art
de gagner juste comprendre
j'en profite et prend des deux tours
prend des deux essais finir ouais on
n'en est rien tu reprends des deux je
vois pas de fous ces trois tours d un
jeu voire joie pas tu vois pas je pas de
problème pour après police y jouer tour
ces deux mais bon en fait le tout est
bien défendu le cavaliere que tu peux
pas trop l'attaqué il faut juste un
petit peu faire revenir la tourache 4 d
une fois que c'est fait c'est bon il
faut faire un petit peu attention
ouais un peu beaucoup quand même parce
que tour des gardes turaci ce tour de
suisse je te champions 6-1 3-6 7-6 mais
il faut c'est qu'à pêcher
alors oui il faut c'est qu'à te tue
préparatoire à la fac flot de ces choses
là parce que tactique
mais bon au moins juqu'en débarrasser du
cloche de la paix faut absolument
trouver le moyen de d'activer la tour
mais elles contrôlent bien un peu juge
trois peut-être fou prend bessin oui
vous prend bessat et surtour d un fouet
faingaa fond mais juste sur fond et tu
craches 3g peu importe
très tranquille avec sang-froid et en
plus c'est l'aimer autant elle va
prendre la tête je sais pas mais les
deux je vende peut-être en arménie c'est
très très grosse très grosse culture et
culinaires la tête cinq greffes 6
peut-être intéressant pour le pour le
match leur tour j'ai quatre carats lieu
saint caprais non mais très clairement
là c'est fini
donc elle va prendre mais elle va
prendre le elle va prendre le lead et
c'est plutôt je dirais un début de match
qui est vraiment al'avantage de la
joueuse arménienne dans le sens où dans
le jeu courant elle a vraiment l'air de
dominer
je suis d'accord et en plus c'est la
prom a alors dit pourquoi leur revient
là dessus oui parce qu'en fait les ya eu
un problème dans les deux ailes étaient
pas très bien quand tout à l'heure non
françaises elles étaient mal et
finalement la même si elle était un peu
moins bien c'est peut-être la position
qu'elle a le mieux maîtrisé finalement
puisque la france de la française elle a
quand même eu un peu de réussite faut
l'admettre
j-6 hockey j'aime bien à première vue ce
coup j'ai six parce que tu mets tout et
pions sur blanc donc tu prends un peu le
parti de quelles armes thème un petit
côté greer ouais mais ok tu va couvrir
il s'est fait refouler cette envie
d'essayer de mettre le foin 3-2 spatiale
et tu vas faire carrière au début
j'allais dire qu'avec six parfois que je
parlais cavaliers 7 et l'autre cas
valiant et sinueux ses sauces et encore
une fois une histoire de peur de fou
mais je trouve que cette structure est
assez compact
bien sûr il convient bien pour lutter
contre la peur de fou c'est toute façon
de foot doivent pas être actif ici ouais
c'est c'est génial moi je préfère jouer
ça finalement que d'avoir le fou qui
restent bloquées ans et 8 ou même des
fois qu'il s'est fait piéger en f 5
dernièrement c'est un peu comme ça que
j'essaie de jouer quand je jouais mais
slave pour pour pas tu as à me
débarrasser il faut que le cavalier
après mac les pions sur blanc ses trois
que blanc je pense passer le ko allait
en g3 essayé d'attaquer le roi 7 h 50 le
prend dans le carde jamais dire ça et m
le kenyan des cinq peut-être est-ce que
tu te faire f 5 fu de 3e sont j'ai
toujours peur de faire ça mais ici ça
marche peut-être de manière concrète à
leurs biens
tu vois la socat si tu prends que
répondant vous faire taper par la foule
m en fous fin tu menaces e400 menacé
puisque a poussé quatre échecs
donc je vais justement pour les
auditeurs sfr f5 tous les trois ou cinq
qui est souvent il fabrique c'est une
idée intéressante faut toujours regarder
et c'est vrai que 6e 4 était si le roi
est en âge suite c'était je pense très
fort mais là avec le fou ces quatre
échecs gros ça se joue quand même à mon
avenir
ça pouvait jouer quand même un fou c'est
qu'à te faire voir je suis têtu peut
jouer pour eux quatre cavaliers ce qui
est des cinq ça me paraissait pas pas
idiot mais après ce qu'elle a fait
qu'ils aient des 5 c'est aussi non même
honte à toi que tu veux te faire chasser
quand même en c4 arrive ou c3 les plans
si petit qu'on ne se cette structure
ouais après tu peux jouer quoi avec les
noirs et attendre enfin faire un peu
comme dans la première partie finalement
même si en revanche le four g6 parfois
il est bien placé parce que ça te permet
de jouer sur la case f4 laon g7 donc à
lui vraiment faire ses gammes sous ses
trois services d'impression le bas
touchés tels que ses 5e jeux sont bons
en attaque si cap puisque après tout ces
trois mais tous ses trois cahiers de son
bref ou c3 qui est des cinq leur tour
ces trois sons qu'il tu prends du
cavalier mais c'est 3 tu prend
l'intervalle et on a eu ce mot qui
accueille 5 et s'arrête juste égalisait
en force
ok donc finalement décidé donc elle va
les fous est ce qu'elle va faire pousser
quatre fautes à bien son coup droit je
pense qu'il y ait des stones ouais c'est
pas bien vous avez quatre peut-être du
coup bien ouais c'est sûr qu'ils aient
des 5 et ab4 bien et pro 3 je vais
montrer la variante qui est des cinq du
coût élevé à la façon des 4,43 y avait
pu en france et 5 et la dame et attaquer
le cavaliere aussi une classe il
renouvelle la menace avec à
trois-bassins la carte est belle de
faire cavalier à 4 et à l' empêche qui a
aidé 5
donc il faut probablement bouger la dame
peut-être ça s'est mal goupillé pour les
mois où k et 17
je le défends est une cavalière catch
them ce set
surtout que bouger la dame sur quel
cadre ouais c'est ça tu as ton cavalia
cut pro b dames puisque dame sait si
t'as pas le droit edd ha me prend il
faut penser cinq dames c'est cette ya
peut-être du cavalier b5 qui rôde et je
sais pas c'est pas encore que
mais bon ça ne pas envie mais qu'à
relief des sages j'aime bien ton coup et
c'est ce qu'elle joue d'ailleurs bon
ménage avec cavalière à 4 tout prendre
c'est ça tu es prendre 17 mai ya
peut-être b2 qui tombera la fin octobre
et 8 tours prend b2 parce qu'on peut
éventuellement tout prendre je sens que
tu as eu une déconnexion nom de jazz
comme en main ce que je lisais le chat a
utilisé le chat ya un mec qui a besoin
d'aller dehors je pense sortir de faire
une soupe de solides il ya des trolls
possible je pourrais modéré ce à tout
moment non mais c'est plus dommage pour
lui ça c'est sûr wassa banon du coup
cette petit avantage blanc très
clairement après j'aime bien évoluer en
ce sens alors fonctionne trois solides
ouais les noirs ils sont ceux qui s'en
sont bien sortis et comme d'hab
tu vas faire ou 5ème semaine ces trois
jeux suite aux cinq absents que sam on
pense avant qu'elles sont bons ce passé
est classique tu pousses sa majorité
ta maman est allée droit et envoie donc
l'idée de cette fois je suis tel point
que 5 4
ensuite je passais obligé à me tapant du
top qu'on avait chacun après avec les
plans à foot à jouer si je jouais b4
vite un qu'elle prend une fois elle va
faire tour des 8 du coût auquel cas ce
qui se passe si on prend prend des 8es
on feb et 4 après foucher 5
on saura jamais
je suis tellement tenté par essayer de
chasser le cavalier de rentrer avec
madame en baisse est donc il ya père de
fou seb majorité allèles dame donc céder
les points positifs pour les blancs mais
les noirs très solide pas vraiment de
faiblesses
après si les bleus réussissent à ce
qu'un pion passé à ça peut devenir
vous-même b d'ailleurs ça peut devenir
dangereux est ce qu'on est ce qu'on s'y
ajoutent jectif subjectif sur les
commentaires comme tu veux donc du coup
c'est plus drôle de ce dispositif
oui oui soit supprimé du coup les noirs
sont complètes je pense qu'avoir sont
gagnants on va voir t'as pas peur de b 4
à 5 à 6
non et j'étais très bons arguments
bon bah voilà flèche deux échecs
attention aux faux f4 bien joué par
contre je ferai pas malade mais normale
normale à tension fou prend ses 5 qu'est
ce que tu rentres dans dix-sept bon
calcul prend du plomb du cou et une gêne
un peu oui peut-être c'est pas con ça
s'apprend c'est 5 tu prends tu prend du
plomb et du gène un peu des cas oui les
gens que dans les deux cas ils pourront
jamais être attaqué mais ceci est point
c'est simple c'est tranquille nul minuit
je joue bien je joue vraiment bien cette
chose armenian bien sûr tu crois pas
mais je la voyais pas si forte
chabris allez on prend la colonne
d'hommes d66 d'amener 6 par al mouna ce
monstre aide maintenant talent d'alain
cavalier comptable fous que tu voulais
voir tout à l'heure et d'un dessin bus
tu pourras même menacé du dante un dame
prend 1,5
c'est sa saison dame de six zones mal à
jouer
et tu sais que les noirs sont mieux bien
sûr non mais là je vais faire hausse le
seuil de 5 400 même je peux peut-être
prendre h 50 fink avantage leroy 2 1
peut-être prolongé 6 j'ai l'impression
qu'il un roman si tu te fais prendre le
pion peut-être tu le revoit jamais que
les oui c'est vrai qu'en plus il
dédramatise de toute façon tu la placera
jamais droit à un hockey lors de damages
2 moi j'allais dire la région c'est ça
c'était mon coup pour pour les noirs
aussi on est peut-être qu'on aille au
fond mais en fait tu regardes je prends
mon match dont tu fais d'un match si je
fais dameuse cinq échecs d'un médecin
ait eu bloque tout pareil quand tu sais
que les noirs étaient gagnants c'est
être complètement objectif je crie elle
appelait il ya un truc marrant je pense
est sur b4 triste prise
quel point accueil et d'un de combes et
catéchèse du recteur mais peut-être que
du coup je peux faire dame
ouais non j'ai pas de perpète j'ai pris
ma culotte
et donc voilà c'est un gars le fairway
heureuses je sais pas pourquoi me leroy
sur sur reims apparaissait tout de suite
est une case un peu si je déteste la
scala ferracci g5l john mc alger 6 ou
alors qu'elle te jure roger 7-6 7/2
moi je jouerai dam des cinq là avec une
petite menace de cavaler points 4 encore
très envie de hockey 900 custom c'est
bien mais droite s'il faut juste
contrôler que la dame blanche contre pas
qu'avec les blancs tu as envie de faire
dame des quatre ici est-ce que tu dois
pas être obligé de le faire
gérard sans que la finale ait pas times
qui avait perdu quatre cavaliers avis si
c'est plus rare cinq tombes mais bon
deux côtés tête on a dû contre je suis
bon je pas sûr que tu rentres en fait
les pions beil te bloque bien non ça a
l'air bien pointe même à mais que faire
abandonner haïti va abandonner et p4 ici
ça marche pas pourquoi pas du tout ouais
bah là tu fais juste g4 et dames de son
jeu la rentrée sur les cases blanches la
belgique a valu aux canards et f4 à ça
me paraît horrible tu donnes tellement
de cases trois coups son homme de son
âge - 4 bien jouer c'est lui prend le
gagne un jour tu as qui prend b2 on veut
tous aller blonds ou blancs honneur mais
elle a très mal joué avec les blancs bon
encore une petite incertitude sur le
tangue ménagers de ces horribles à
l'esquissé 5 et les changes les dames et
c'est de plus en plus facile à gagner là
j'ai l'impression
on peut même aller chercher à chansons
qui l'éclairé passé et puis en plus
quand tu arrives en achetant qui
menacent g3 wave au nombre desquels très
facile de métaux dans étonnant étonnant
étonnant katia sur cette partie quand
même c'est un peu faiblard ce qu'elle a
fait bon c'est un peu faiblard quand
même écoute on écoute le tribut oui non
mais elle joue bien et non mais je ne
minimise pas la performance des noirs
attention de danielli ans je dis juste
que quelqu'un monde celle qui nous a dit
que c'était plus de 25 e concept de
nîmes
areva écoute c'est pas étonnant 25/20
est moins gros stylo 25e 1 il fait que
débite sur internet
ouais mais c'est ça on la voit plus dans
les grands championnats
elle a changé elle fait que des beats et
ça qu'elles allaient à leur pénible
aller 25 25 25 10 25 ans sur deux
jusqu'à 20 c c'est déjà pas à ça ça fait
déjà pas mal
hélas sa carrière de vraiment bien joué
bon la mode un peu ses dépens et jouer
la finale
tu peux te barrer que la dame ce point
on va le voir les deux contre deux deux
blindés de pièces pas grand chose mais
j'ai toujours su que tous les deux un
peu chiant rapport aux 6 et 8 qui peut
toujours faire elle domina en finale sk
n'a pas envie de ben oui mais c'est tout
dire parce que pour moi
4 j'ai pris des finales aussi oui elle
est supposée être très très très très
fort qu'en finale mais la dame de 3 seul
coup et il va faire elle va faire quoi
le faire h 3 x 3 histoire de taper avec
les deux coups sûrs je peux peut-être
angers 5 une tournée un genou 3 quel fou
3 c'est logique et simon c'est pour
essayer de taper a7 dans le sens où si
tu fais b6 tout
le fou alger 2 nous il faut aussi ce
logique aussi sur dame psa qui va avoir
des soucis à avoir mais bon alors je
vais très vite donc c'est plus théorique
tandis que le cône sur le thème de cette
je sais pas qu'elle se situe à non je
suppose et tu vois pas ce que je sais
pas tu fais quoi si tu prends ces gages
pendant ces 6 et jean font plus si tu
fais tour [ __ ] qu'on a cette fois levé
2 et je peux comme celle ci c'est que
ces quatre mais cinq longs plus aussi en
plus c'est plutôt les blancs qui ont
l'activité ici bas tu perds jamais ça
avec le moins il y aura des mecs de mon
avance tous très contents je sais pas ou
alors on loupé un truc qu'on veut nous
en tout cas j'imagine qu'on n'est pas
les seuls à y réfléchir parce que si
elle a pris autant de temps et surtout
aussi c'est qu'elle regardait à la
paperie on a dû rater un truc basso soit
la prit peur vu que katy a utilisé que
deux sportives
c'est quand même concession d'art fait
d'un bep trois dames à 4 du coup je suis
bon teint regarde qui émeut développer
l'accès à tête une idée amarante ses
cahiers des cinq général après ça pas
marché parce que ma fille on prend lyon
prend et dame 17 rue mais sinon qui est
des cinq ça peut être un truc thématique
belle idée de damas que tu montes dans
le cher je pense que c'était pour éviter
de blesser un qu'avec le gauche oui la
demande des trois pas super bien placé
d'accueil chevaux 600 fasse une
corruption c4 s'arrête à raison la
pollution restera agréable à jouer pour
les blancs mais je pense nous feras tu
peux commencer à échanger un peu hein
pas si facile de trouver h3 bien jouer
autant que sky les cats avec les draps
dur de trouver un coup ouais tu vois la
tour à huit la dame a capté pas madame
en surveillant peu à 7
ouais un coup comme ainsi sait jamais
trop envisageable parce que ça affaiblit
trop les cases noires donc on peut pas
vraiment se débarrasser du problème et
en revanche est ce que voient les tours
s'est vite y aura au pire dame prend 1,7
ouais non parce que tu es je me disais
on peut être ces drames et la tour donc
cavalier 17 finalement logique elle veut
peut-être travailler jusqu'à l'hiver
pays si vous préparez f54 aussi
l'occasion à ja désidé kébé si samassa
forces plus ou moins fous prouver si
cela pour la peine parce que c'est qu'un
joker visas belges que tu vas pas jouer
b3 tranquille qui avait b6 damas
ceinture au cou et du coup sûr b3 f5 way
de trois secondes
c'est assez actif mais l'idée c'est de
faire c'est de faire 4 et de te vous
peut-être la m 4 d'ailleurs est ce que
cache cache dans son regard de main et
chasser des fous et d'essayer de
m'activer à fond sur les droits parce
que c'est vrai que les dames sont un peu
bloqué à l'été pièces sont un peu bloqué
à la dame je cherche je regarde f4 pour
les blues salomon tourisme
avec quatre points le vent ça ouais bon
la ja québécismes tête des trois et cinq
à quatre vingt dix mois à temps est ce
que je vaux un coup bizarre ces 5
bah c'est pas bizarre c'était pas
bizarre a écrit des reds vainqueurs
quatre des six matchs contre le cavalier
de sept ans de plus les troubles ont
fait 3 hockey balle en pince à f/5 bon
et normal c'est aussi tu faire pousser
l'autre manier et valier jouer à 5 ont
empêché b4 ça ressemble un truc pas mal
est-ce que cavaler dessins que tu
voulais porter est possible il semble
que oui
après ben laden de bouger en est vite du
coup et peut-être parions que tu
bougez lecavalier après j'ai quatre là
j'en suis bloqué après quand je joue ça
dans mes parties j'ai toujours que je
cherche la merde pour pas grand chose
non mais je pense que c'est jouer à la
fête ou rêves d'hier alors se fout c'est
ça qui avait été fondée sous du coup que
ce sont des cas et c5 bien joué parce
que vous prononcez cinq est quasi forcée
non la dame est enfermé mais du coup le
fou maintenant on s'est senti très bien
et c'est de nouveau la paire de fou
ouais mais bon car il ya eu quatre
scénarios de karachi possède ses 5 à ya
peut-être des études la cause des saints
comme ça peut-être le temps de jouer
c'est parce que les noirs vont jamais
joué ses cinq amies hkd ont calmé les
pions mais la dame blanche pas ou font à
la du mal à revenir
ouais elle est complètement refait le
monde commençait à l'attaqué de l'autre
côté nation c'est ce qu'elle fait avec
achi se le faire être cinq ok c'est pas
mal de choses à ok tuant trois
évidemment à cette dame est en moi peut
toujours pas bouger cet d'hommes mais
peut-être tu peux faire bcap non
affaissée sas et auquel vous jouez de
bkc cinq façons c'est fade america sur
abc ouais pour peut-être elle veut juste
faire h5 affaiblir un peu le roi rbds et
6 us que ses gommes je donne cette fois
bloqués dans les quatre dames vraie dame
des quatre matches le pion est sûre b6
dame c3 on attaquera à 5 km du coup
peut-être damas trois dames d2 le 3 way
le faire sous x 3 autour des hanches
pense
est ce que la dame noire qu'ils
limiteraient
via iad a mené 3 jeux fouet fort est une
barre des 7
du coup l'info 2 bon là c'est bizarre de
borges détour d'un coin ouais ça a été
le coup de talon de fer tempo depuis tu
veux me lecavalier ont décidé après la
seconde en a déjà plus de temps elle
redevient donc c'est peut-être jusqu'à
l'avait pris à laver près move où elle
avait juste prévu de faire des maths
royal a pas le cas peut-être quatre là
un peu mal aux 6 me stresse le pouls des
coûts visant à elle fait n'importe quoi
en faut vraiment katia égalise l'un par
égalise reviennent au score
il ya deux points d'écart elle pourra
pas égalisant d'une partie la vallasse
four b2 four b2 milo elle le voit pas du
coup nous tu l'as vu ouais ok alors
d'occasion tu refais tour c'est un allez
faut jouer court c'est un tempo che
penserait donc repartir en dix-sept non
non mais bon ok aux 2 ou la laisser un
gros truc avec bon après c'est quand
même c'est quand même dur pour les blu
ray mais c'est quand même dur c'est
d'ailleurs ce que tu attaques sert à
rien belle halte en plus de luxe et
paraissent bien calculée par à tfo v2
c'est quand même gros seins ça va être
80 et là c'est maintenant par ap d'un
match de hockey bas c'est bien pour le
match quand même une nouvelle fois
danielian un poil lente mais sûre cette
partie mais sinon bien défendu donc en
réalité les parties qu'elle perd c'est
toujours un peu le même scénario
elle est un peu moins bien ce qu'on
s'est quand même
même scénario ce alors que quand elle
allait installer les noires en tout cas
c'est de la défoncer un moment donné ça
compte et ça passe ou ça passe pas et
quand elle allait blonde pas trop
d'ambition dans le début en général mais
l'attention des foules armées qui
essaient même scénario des parties we ll
raphaël est un peu avec elle est un peu
moins bien avec les noirs et puis après
si elle joue vite si elle joue vite et
que l arrivants
dans une finale pas clair qu'elle tient
elle retourne la position très souvent
très bon jeu en finale et en revanche
quand elle et quand elle est un peu
juste autant c'est katia qui gagne oui
c'est ça ça le temps toujours joué en sa
défaveur
lorsqu'elle arrive pas bien géré et
quant à elle quand elle tombe en dessous
de la minute elle réussit pas à rester
elle trouve les coups on peut mais c'est
dur de jouer pendant vingt coups avec
quelques semaines je tourne kikla
l'impression que ça joue très solide des
deux côtés c'est vrai que c'est pas un
jeu hyper offensif mais c'est aussi dû
aux ouvertures tu prends l'option des
codes civil nous peut-être par le ch a
dit tout ce qui se passait sur d'un
prend des quatre dans cette position
nous avons des cas tous les noms j'en
peux plus
monette alors elle a fait j'ai this way
mais c'est jamais facile ses positions
avec les blancs on l'a bien vu 1 dans ce
match c'est karo kann c'est quand même
dur à percer un mais comment le doit
remettre ses papiers ça joue vite chaud
suite j'ai cette transposition g5 mais
après j'ai conçu comme taylor elle va
jouer des changes des dames et après
mais c'est tout et c'est 5 rapide aux du
mali il ya combien de temps encore sur
son banc je vais dire ça tout de suite
il reste 18 minutes donc à mon avis
reste de partir je pense c'est là une
autre ça devrait ça devrait être tout
parce que les parties durent un peu plus
de dix minutes on a quand même des
longues parties 1 depuis tout à l'heure
est-ce que b4 peut être une idée ici
avec les plans ouais non décote
je veux des gardes c'était pour essayer
de jouer avec fougue et non mais je te
fais besoin quelques noix peut-être b3
four b2 du coup était une idée mais ce
profond de deux jeunes grecs se fout en
b2 il serait bien
ouais bah oui c'est 4 tu peux jouer
après pour des 5 es ok peut-être fou des
schistes du coup tu es ici cette fougère
c4 bon prologue à huy c4 direct foot et
6 et 4 exact voilà tout
damages 5
est-ce que tu as quand même pas envie de
faire d'un courage 5 est fou et 3 et
jouer cette finale
pas sûr non non non parce que ça va
arriver vite soudé si je pense pas mais
la laddh à moins qu'elle ait pas si oui
ou non elle assez mal placé surtout que
les plans peuvent peut-être placé leur
tour en e1 du coup pour essayer de viser
16h05
elle a réussi une nouvelle fois une
bonne position mais elle va se retrouver
avec le même rapport matériels mais tout
à l'heure c'est vraiment la marque de
fabrique du ouais faut contre cavaliers
dans des pots chez swatch two way cette
thématique en plus c est ce qui manque
c'est que ces dépositions le fou d'un
point de vue scolaire est peut-être
légèrement plus fort mais en réalité
en réalité non et puis dans ce format
cavaliers c'est bien toujours de type
mais hmm hmm hmm en longues ses
positions âge bah oui certainement
pour moi le club vit plus au retour d'un
match 6 d'un mec qui va briser la casa
pia a une nouvelle fois elle a réussi
dans sa car au cas n'a pas joué solide a
complètement égaliser joue pas mal
vraiment elle menace est des dames des
deux mois je suis assez fan franchement
on ne l'attendait pas à ce niveau là
c'est ben may mais tu te souviens on a
dit à vancouver les cavaliers en fait
parce que même on a trouvé une partie où
elle le gagne
dans une finale où elle a juste dame
cavaliers et aux tatum gratuit pour
contre ce petit coin qui commentent en
qui est quand même 24 quelque chose qui
est qui et commentatrice du speech est
féminin
en anglais sur la chaîne sur la chaîne
de chasse comme et voilà le commencer
maria tour de tours de qu'elles n'ont
qu'à reprendre sa marche pas mais bon ok
tu dis et puis on va repartir en h6
bêtement et puis elle menace les reliefs
mosquée d'el qods où la dance 3 bon
alors après avec les noirs généralement
là tu dois juste en rusant 10 ans russes
ont dit ça soit tu dois juste à voir
oui même si tu peux dire en coin ouais
il fut de citoyens ça se dit ok c'est
bien joué surtout on prend le faire
cavalier 47.59 pour attaquer encore way
est comme ça surprend mais qui oublie
cinq courses et si cette prise prise
comme d'hab' top coat alors un lucho en
b 5e qui fait pas grand chose car la
différence sarlat et ans et 5
ouais c'est vrai et c'est là du coup ça
fait qu'il est mieux ont déçu parce que
des qpc cas tu donnes casse brique est
difficile de faire des cats 7 jours/7
prendre un bon thème la question la dame
h 6 kg dames gestion assez assez
épineuse question la question de cette
dame qui tu sais quoi je préfère quand
même cela pour les blancs que tout à
l'heure qui existait déjà mais elle ne
voit pas trop de cannes peut-être joué
avec bkb quatre ans et trois belles
saisons et en fait cavaler de ces sites
il tient aussi aux six usa mais les
petits sacrifices récupérer ensuite mais
est ce que tu as le droit de le fou ces
4 milliards f 5 1 peut-être oui et
justement le cas ali qui réussit ce qui
empêche vous prend aussi ses chèques la
physique études en crise ouais afu c4 5
tours 8 double échec
ah oui non regarde ya peut-être une
belle variante ya ces quatre là
peut-être matrix et 4,5
non mais on s'est toujours dit mais bon
si tu prenais la dame y avait toujours
eu huit doubles et j y crois j'essais
tour cet échec 3 m6 tous rêvent cette
masse mais oui tu prenais juste en haut
du coup elle a joué b4 est sur b4 juste
on prend ces trois noms c'est le cas et
puis on prend à cinq bons elle n'a pas
dû trouver mieux que ça voilà la
majorité plus si terrible à moins qu'on
arrive à pic et 17 et là ça sera super
cool dans notre connais mes tours c5
bien joué et les et visuellement les
tours et du tour blanche sont bien
placés mais en fait elle tape sur un mur
elle joue bien c'est pose en fait saniez
liam elle joue vraiment bien ces
positions des deux qui peut rue très
solide un dans le tusson qu'elle a
l'habitude de s'exprimer
oui tu n'en mets à la l adl à elle à
elle a des bonnes mains quoi elle sait
vraiment ce qu'elle fait et ne le coup
j'aurais jamais joué non pour ses 1 mort
et fait peur avec l'idée de besoin
d'amis g7 tempo pour revenir on se
trompe c'est un truc c'est que tu peux
pas faire tout reprend c'est parce que
la tour d2 qui traînent tour bien ok je
prends un jeune homme de deux je pense
un ouais mais ça avait une tellement
mauvaise tête trois tours b donnant away
non mais en fait tu as l'impression
qu'elle souhaite tellement pas quoi
faire que récent idées à l'apathie des
avantages mais peut-être pas si simple
c'est vrai qu'un petit peu exceptionnel
h5 bien joué mais carey les prends
j'aime bien tout reprend et à bientôt
reprendre demain des ouais mais on peut
mettre la toa dame en f3 peut-être mais
bon oui savait pas grand intérêt quoi
rentrer dedans des deux bien joué et
empêché ce fils qui pouvait créer des
réseaux je me demande si avec les blancs
tu dois pas essayer de jouer b6
pour remettre décès de m dames en f3 et
un peu tout tenir mais bon là je vais
céder son dieu d'amour avec nous
oui tu feras d'amd 5
ok dame m3 dam des 5es h 6 échecs
peut-être oui pour essayer de mais bon
c'est peut-être encore des trucs qu elle
tapote sur dix est pas mal on tient ou
7h plus qu'en fait 3g 2 thomas sainte a
pas le temps il y aura dam des cinq
échecs ketura ans pas mal d'à priori
elle joue pour tours à huit
ouais et d'arrêt c'est bon t'as toujours
d'un machisme pour des sanctions tombent
à nantes a passé 38 dam des catadores
les charges des dames à force de changer
d'amis très bien joué alors il est
surtout assez tueur à tour 17 et de
goûter était obligée de le faire parce
que sinon avec l'amp égal mais l'argent
est tombé ce que vrai laurent va monter
et savoir faire plus de penner douce et
c'est vraiment inquiétant pour qatar
parce que c'est exactement ce que tu
dises l'impression que ça donne c'est
jusqu'à la pas elle n'a pas les réponses
contre ce système là il faut peut-être
qu'elle change complètement de je sais
pas à quel point elle sait jouer autre
chose que le 4 mai petit il faut qu'elle
change la mener d'autres types de
structures mais le truc c'est que les
structures savent savait pas trop marché
non plus mais cela d'un dans les slaves
dans les vrais slave
tu peux quand même un peu plus mettre le
feu je pense tout cas elle a besoin de
trouver des positions elle peut attaquer
son adversaire parce qu'elle passe en
finale elle ne domine pas du tout c'est
même plutôt l'inversé en milieu de jal a
annoncé la nasa
je suis dessus dans l'hérault c5 et puis
la pluie au kansas et 24 mois ouais et
cd sénat c'est un scénario qui commence
vraiment à se répéter
peut-être que katia sera un petit peu un
petit peu de vent dans les bulles est
quand même parce que la guerre du jeu
plus vite
là elle est mal autant mais c'est quand
elle est pas bien dans cette question du
temps non un peu plus vite je pense de
manière générale qui a donc peut-être f5
dans ce cas-là départ mais bon
maintenant j'arrive en d5 jeu là on s'en
fiche de perdre deux tubes et parce
qu'on a battu les deux côtés le roi
clarisse tomber litres donc là elle avec
le roi entre détroit pour éviter
l'option danse voilà tu fais trois là
encore pas d'erreur ouais ouais tu
sembles qu'elles maîtrisent bien ça pour
des joueurs de ce niveau là c'est pas
oui oui mais bon comme moi j'ai ça
m'inquiète ça hips je vais vous jouez
tempore de toute façon c'était fini donc
ça fait ça refait plus de et il reste
combien de temps je vais dire ça tout de
suite il reste huit minutes
donc c'est la dernière donc c'est la
trop très probablement la dernière oui
puisque tu vois la dernière elle à la
précédente elle fait un peu plus de dix
minutes deux parties est la leur à elle
fait aux 3l change
ok mais à 36 poses bénigne et elle était
pas mal dans cette partie-là gagner sa
place à la gagner cette partie c'était
le déclic je dirais pour être belle
j'ai fait c'est important pour elle de
maximiser la vence pour préparer le le
bullet où l'agglo était un peu oui on
verra aussi en trois puissants et déjà
le changement de cadence est ce que ça
change la vie est loin du match
aussi la petite pause entre les parties
que c'est parfois les cinq minutes de
pause ça peut ça peut aussi influer est
ce que tu penses qui se vérifie des
trucs qu'ils ont quelqu'un qui les
acquièrent dénommé la danse est dans le
vrai alors après du coup je j'ai un
doute là dessus parce que j'ai ouï dire
que c'était pas très légal de faire ça
ok mais d'un autre côté de ce que je
sais plus où moins tout le monde le fait
mais ça me paraît hyper dur de que ce
soit pas autorisé de faire ça je sais
pas c'est comme si à la mi-temps entre
entre les matchs de foot l'entraîneur a
quand même le droit de venir te parler
tu vois moi ça va tu as ça me choque pas
que ce soit autorisé le coach tennis n'a
pas l'aura alors en tennis masculin non
en tennis féminin ci a bon ben ya un
changement drake tennis féminin
maintenant le coach peut venir 3 4 fois
par match ou deux fois par set où une
fois par set
c'est plus exactement et la règle alizé
cornet est ce qu'on fait on s'est rendu
compte que c'était cool de l'avoir
longuement fait la raison la raison
profonde c'est qu'ils se sont rendu
compte que ça améliorer le niveau des
matchs eux et donc il considère que pour
le public c'est plus intéressant
bêtement ça évite d'avoir sa saveur est
de remettre un petit coup de boost aux
filles qui parfois tu vas perdre et un
peu le fil du match
du coup mais donc comme dans la plupart
de même même au tennis maintenant c'est
autorisé enfin tennis féminin le rire
alizé cornet c'est extraordinaire voici
quelques vidéos sont pas non plus c'est
son extrême elle est tellement
insupportable sur le court spécial après
je pense que je serai sensiblement
pareil donc on va pas critiquer je pense
que dans ce genre insupportable je serai
je serai pas un comme benoît paire ou
tout ça tu vas sur un peu de vin peut
dans ce délire là ça sera la faute des
faux rebonds des ramasseurs de balle de
l' arbitre juge de touche
c'est quoi le pas ce qu'on nous demande
on nous a demandé les pourquoi il ne
joue pas ce que marie ce bagasse et
chance c'est que je sais pas si wayne
mari est dans le tableau et marie-jo
racontera ricard premier tour facile
ouais apprenait ce bien mariés
bien et wii iphone je pense autant elle
ne tient pas la route ce conte rona cas
mais autant je pense qu'elle défend tout
le monde est sinon elle serait grande
favorite après elle joue pas donc on
sera pas une façon oui mais c'est la
même pas plus envie de jouer du tout ah
ouais on la voit plus trop non tu veux
dire que tu as une ampoule non non j'ai
pas d'infos jugé cette impression j'ai
l'impression qu'on la voit plus trop je
sais pas qu'avec quand est ce qu'on l'a
vu la dernière fois qu'on la voyait de
partout dans un moment et puis là j'ai
l'impression qu'on la voit plus puis a
eu aussi c'est vrai que l'histoire à
gibraltar le match aller
ok j'arrête de jeu à cause de ça non
mais ça dénote je veux pas dire dans le
sens où août à 2 juin coup de samedan
sens où ça dénote comme un certain mal
être
auquel cas le comportement sûr c'est pas
le comportement de quelqu'un heureux qui
fit guilhem et machin tu as deux pages
ou et de machins s'énerver pas s'énerver
parce que tu as perdu contre des filles
et tout ça c'est plutôt pas pour moi
c'est une plutôt le comportement de
quelqu'un qui ce maillot parce que tu as
perdu qu'on n'utilise pas ce que tu
joues qu'on est si oui toujours été à
paris non mais ça pour moi ça dénote
d'un mal-être en fait fin de mon point
de vue après tu as et de la psychologie
de comptoir ça c'est je lâche aucune
info tu as dit à l'étudiant en
angleterre ouais j'ai entendu un truc
comme ça après comme j'ai pas de répit
vont faire des études s'empêche pas non
plus jouer aux échecs face à ce niveau
là ils sont ceux nés dans mon donc tour
c'est un seb et
écoutons qui reste quand j'aurai offert
un petit point il reste trois minutes
trente de jeu dans cette cadence et
qu'est ce que tu penses de cette
position parce qu'il ya de nouveau un
pion isolé en d4
bah c'est pas le même nom il ya aussi un
piolet je voulais parler soit on allait
parler de ces si tu avais pas parlé de
d4 intéressés à moi je supporte les
blancs on m'a parlé d'union des quatre
courants inquiétude je ne veux pas
parler le c'est tabou c'est ça c'est à
vous de moi je ne parle pas des
problèmes tu parle pas des problèmes
auxquels est ce qu'on peut te faire
cavaler b6 du coup histoire d'être coupé
l'herbe sous ça m'embête un peu
kébé si je pense d'ailleurs à vue on va
un peu de couper l'herbe sous le pied et
du coup un tour c'est vrai mais c'est 5
ha je ne prends pas ça tu peux peut-être
faire non non je vais faire des 5 es tu
vois je vais faire tour c'est un c5 des
cinq essayer de jouer sur la fin on y
croit faiblissent non mais non ça m'a
l'air d'être assez pourri jordan prend
juste est ce que le fait que les fous
sous une couleur opposée joue un rôle
dans défonce du pur isolé wen mais
beaucoup plusieurs à défendre pour toi
c'est plus dur à défendre mais est ce
que tu peux pas contre attaquer un peu
nous dit un souci de micros j'ai un
soucis de micro à tanger l'hommage
qu'ils ont tous à vélo
ouais c'est possible que j'aie à tanger
un truc bizarre avec mon micro et attend
c'est très bizarre
tonton que d'une oreille ouais attend
c'est c'est exact l'oreille gauche où
ils auraient droit d'asile à gauche
c'est c'est exact je vois qu'il ya un
souci micro mais je sais ça vient
d'arriver
c'est peut-être un bug de mon micro ton
micro pour te gauche ouais alors c'est
absolument anormal c'est absolument
anormal alors attendez c'est un problème
ok c'était un bug et je pense que ces
reçus dans l'un des deux oreilles non
mais c'était un problème avec le
le le programme de streaming je le
voyais aussi visuellement hockey ouais
merci les mecs
c'était un bug et on nous a dit qu'on
était deux mines
ces nombres bah ouais mais c'est les
premières pages non c'est cool oui c'est
cool c'est cool pas mais je suis très
heureux mais bon c'est l'habitude
maintenant
quant à les premières pages c'est on est
on est tout le temps en tout le temps
nombreux mais c'est bien d'avoir deux
mille voix de tenir deux mille personnes
c'est bien mais ça veut dire que c'est
intéressant ce qu'on fait ok j'ai vu
qu'il y avait deux trois questions de
plus perso on fait un petit moment
question perso oui oui mais là en fait
tant qu'on est concentré qu'on est dans
le match comme je sais que ces matchs
sont non je sais qu'à un moment donné on
va un peu lâché ses yeux pas ici dans
les supers chaumont commenté tout en
découd après avoir pris des coups c'est
ça dont il faut profiter tant qu'on est
temps qu'on est chaud pour parler
d'échec et qu'on est motivé qu'on se
fait plaisir en regardant généralement
le truc c'est de
voilà c'est d'être là dedans mais à un
moment donné dans le iii plus simple
généralement à la moitié ou tu as envie
de tu décroches un peu ce qui est normal
par contre je vois plus de fusionner et
pourtant nous égalité moteur oui mais
pas dire mais j'ai l'impression que le
muret vii sis f5 contrôle bien ton
foulée 3 je vois ton argument je vais me
faire un pion passé très vite et tu vas
- faire le malin tu vas faire à 4 ouais
j'ai essayé de remettre mon fou en f3 au
contrôle et à 8
c'est vrai mais tu es mal autant ah
ouais mais tout de suite
ok je suis mal autant tout est relatif
n'était pas non plus mal de chez mal
mais c'est vrai que quand on regarde
bien le joker pas très conventionnel
joue bien j'ai tout vraiment bien avec
les blancs hockey pour haïti cependant
qu'elle a juste sauvé 3 tu reviens en
tout cas tu veux si tu veux surtout il
ya peu fou prend b2 prend b2 est ce que
et peut-être prend b2 là elle menace
tour points à 4 et donne des signes
déviation et d'amd 5e chaque toute
tranquillité mais évidemment alors les
blancs vont devoir est ce que les blancs
peuvent et j'allais dire fou c'est 6 mai
poussé 6 ya toujours des fous p3l
revient à passer il n'y a pas trop de un
bon c'est le début du match mais il ya
pas trop de chip cookies pas son nom
mais bon elles en ont raté aussi des
clips au wat banon bombe a énormément
plu
après bon la nature des pauses c'est
peut-être ça vient avec le temps qui
passe
mais comment tu joues fait je suis en
train de me demander quel plantu met en
place avec les noirs parce que j'ai
l'impression que tu peux pas vraiment
améliorée alors qu'elle savait qu'avec
les blancs tu as quand même cette idée
de mettre le foin f3 et pousser ton
pions bah c'est pas si facile hein parce
que ak d'amendés 6 tu vois le propose
une un point physiquement
my world tour à 7
écoutez krejci peau comme une chipie moi
j'écris cheapos c'est h
ap au pas comme une chipolata pas très
saucisses là je suis pas très important
je vérifie pour la ta mère mais j'écris
à j'écris cheapos commun comme commun
comme il faut j'ai envie de dire oui
comme un chapeau sont le avec le est mal
orthographié
c'est un petit moyen de mots techniques
preuves ou alors perdre le mot chip cité
bilingue ou pas d'ailleurs à temps elle
peut pas un auquel peut-être à l'ajout
hyper vite comme j'ai l'impression que
sur certains coups qui me paraissent
critique katia et joue vite et sur
d'autres coûts qui m'aurait paru plus tu
vois on se défonce
qu'est ce qu'elle peut tenter tour d un
faux c'est de faire voilà du coup non p1
mais là non non non elle ne peut pas non
ça c'est pas mal pour mobiliser le four
b3 aller ou retour c8 et puis comme ça
tu te faut aussi aller c'est ok mais non
ça tient peut-être à au conte l'afutt
couleurs opposées duguid b2 mais non
mais dumont et f5 et du coup ils savent
gagner watts alors que la bon ok il ya
encore des mini chance d'ailleurs elle
était nulle mais oui c'est vrai
qu'ensuite j'ai dit comme une blague ce
genre mais c'était possible parce
qu'elle me contre tours pour ado tu veux
faire un point et je pense que m la tour
un rapproché à ça c'est où
ok propose du long congé trois autour
des 3 tours p1 force et un procès pour
des deux a bien joué mais bon tour en a
trois ouais non mais bien joué parce que
tu veux pas perdre f2 mais non mais non
c'est pas moi c'est pas mal non mettront
compte du bon mais salle elle va la
jouer katia avantage avantage là
nul et oui sur tourcoing aussi ça fou
qu'on met deux je suis d'accord mais tu
as quand même vachement un début de la
structure c'est parce qu'on nous dit
c'est donc la fin mais ça ça te donne et
l'ail
objectivement nul si tu laisses la tour
sur la seconde avec les blancs mais tu
as un second avec les noirs je pense que
vu le scénario du match qu'elle essaye
de près move très mou frais move
tu vois un coup quand même qu'à chaque
fois qu'elle abaissait move elle a perdu
un truc
ouais enfin faut quelle voie il faut
qu'elle prenne ou intelligemment gras
vous faire f 4 tu vois mais en pré move
ou quoi allez f4 itunes oui bah oui mais
je veux dire par là qu'il fallait le pré
mou froid et la faim qui remettent un
pion f5
est ce que le fait pas juste le bon truc
en photo la fin des quatre là vous faire
vous des quatre essais bref bref à aller
à l'école et partir pour wave si seth
wescott achetant un bien jeu ok c'est
tranquille tu tiens c'était pas si c'est
ma si tranquille que ça pour qu'on le 3
way s'est pas assis tranquille que ça
non je crois que ça va avec capuche mais
pourquoi parler à huy pour patienter non
non c'est pas si tranquille mais il faut
que les noirs et les blancs mais là pour
juste qu'elles prennent beaucoup en fait
ça ça compte est ce qu'en fait elle peut
elle peut elle peut mettre elle peut
jouer sur cases noires et près elle peut
tout prévu sur quasiment scellé mais
exactement
ouais la tour f 2 qu'elle veut éloigner
le roi des grossistes ont aussi soit mb
5 3 1 auxerre jeu non ce n'était pas une
bonne idée de fond de sacrifier mais
justin c'est plus et même qu'axa qui a
failli tomber au final puisqu'il reste
un point d'eux s'est adjoint un coup
avec 0,2 et égalisation n'ont toujours
un point de retard
ah bon presque way avait deux points il
y avait deux points
quatre ennemis trois et demi maintenant
ok alors elle rejoue mais voilà ça va ça
va s'arrêter puisque c'est la fin celle
du 5 + 1 pièce donc on tourne c'est à
dire moi je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
ah ouais tu peux tu pensais tu pensais
katia on va dire 4 2 l'orgie là je pense
qu on allait se faire un peu chier mais
là non là donc c'est bon on va pas
rester très longtemps parce qu'on va pas
être passer une page de pub et on va et
on va se retrouver dans cinq minutes
ok ça marche la boutique les mecs
[Musique]
donc c'est bon on est de retour yes
on est de retour et c'est bien parce que
les joueuses n'ont pas encore repris
ça va très bientôt reprendre c'est le
capteur donc qu'elles changent pas alors
je crois que c'est la partie qui importe
c'est un oui je me suis dit exactement
la même chose mais c'est la partie qui
aborde t écoute c'est encore profiter
peut-être pour discuter un peu avec le
tchad justement comme on disait lancé
quelques petites questions malaisie si
le soin et ouais j'ai vu qu'on était
assez nombreux dans quoi tu disais je
crois on a eu la première page de twitch
aujourd'hui donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle n'oubliez pas d'ailleurs si
vous êtes nouveau sur sur ce stream à
mettre un petit un petit follow sur la
chaîne chaise comme on sera on
commentera d'autres événements scène
sera plus que probablement de retour
pour pour d'autres commentaires c'était
une première ces mesures ça veut dire
que le match le matching c'est cool tu
es un peu notre porte bonheur
premier match premier beau match ouais
est ce que j'ai une chaîne twitch oui
mais j'ai fait qu'une vidéo les gens
peuvent quand même allez allez follow la
chaîne
ouais ouais bon pourquoi pas mais c'est
sympa c'est sympa twitch de sun j'ai mes
habitudes ouais c'est pas évident en
salle après c'est une habitude c'est un
coup à prendre
il y avait soit tu vas dans le chat qui
s'ennuyait alors attends j'ai juste un
tout petit à temps je pourrai faut que
je fasse un truc c'est ben ok bah du
coup ça a repris encore une française
encore un peu isolées mais c'était
volontaire de la part des noirs sur une
variante ça bloque
ces blocs la case des quatre normal
quand il ya un bon cavalier en d4 et
elle a pas laissé le
7 des 8 mai donc on se demande où il va
réapparaître est fou et 3 plutôt pas mal
joué parce que du coup double est ici
est pas vraiment une option pour les
mois à 5 super agressif bon de toute
façon le cavalier de l'intérieur des
classes
est-ce qu'on bloque avec à 4 c'était une
bonne question et il ya répondu et j'ai
presque envie de faire baisser à
sacrifier le pion je sacrifie défendre
mais derrière il ya les deux campus sur
deux écrans j'essaie de te renvoyer la
balle tu vois je c'est de dire un truc
intelligent tout en étant en train de
régler le problème et pour une raison x
ou y et on voit aussi une idée dessous
des 8 abstient la 5g pas si c'était fait
exprès mais elle est déjà bien avec tout
le monde
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est pas mal
parce que tu fais que les blancs et deux
cavaliers noirs sont très bien
positionnés du coup la dame vient pas
attaquer sur la colonne g24 son prix à
cannes des 4 apple mais si la dame reste
sur la colonne b tu peux envisager du a4
moi j'aime bien les noirs qui a toujours
ce côté un petit peu subjectif des sites
internet attaquer ouais ok donc l art
serait la dame on décide ça paraît pas
mal et à 4 va arriver peut-être même à
trois avec le pion 7,3 en prison ses
parents fait parce que tu donne quand
même un pion de passer à trois jours
c'est concret ce qui est prince étroite
attaquera d1 ouais ouais mais en fait on
reste comme ça tu es tu peux mettre la
pression sur b2 genre déjà ah oui au
cavalier va réapparaître en d3 ouais
c'est j'allais dire lequel il fera peut
être en étroit voire même en d4 donc en
3g bien j'aime bien à 3 elle prend du
pion reprises en c3
voilà et du coup là la caisse du
cavalier vient d'être prise pour
l'apparat tour mais bon elle peut faire
tomber trois cavaliers 2 alors qu'elle
veut qu'est ce que tu veux vraiment
faire avec les blancs en fait parce que
le pion à ta du mal à le pousser pour
l'instant pas plus en plus si tu vas
être bloqué en a quatre et ans à 5 mois
c'est à dire je veux mettre un cavalier
en escales tum tum pressurisé de cinq
oui mais tu pressurise combien de poids
au final battu la tour des 3d font bien
à troisvierges autour de la saison
passée le tour en 8e position
peut-être l'idée de faire crisser 5 et
cavaliers f4 de change était cavale
ouais mais moi je vous aime bien comme
ça s'apprend les caisses de la colonne
de gym auquel amène l'autre et damas six
je pense une séquence intéressante de la
part de katia qui a réussi à remettre
ses cavaliers bien mais au final ils
font pas
voilà peut-être que juste vos f 4 1 pour
les blancs pour protéger latéralement ok
pour ce tour dans la ligne de la dame
quant à la dame et la dame blanche mais
voyait peut-être fait tour à d un
maintenant avec les blancs si je dis
ouais ok ok autour c'est un tour c'est
un j'aime bien le faire tour c'est une
audition ce système auquel elle est
prise il n'y a pas de cheapos pour le
moment ouais h3 c'était quand même pas
mal joué ça évite donc les autres tous
les couleurs la position semble
équilibré mais pas égal dans le sens où
il ya quand même des chances pour les
deux roues ou l'inversé d'ailleurs égal
mais pas utiles et ouais ouais enfin oui
ça dépend dans quel sens sont ils mieux
équilibrée bon le temps va jouer son
rôle déjà trente secondes avance ça peut
être important est ce qu'elle va
repartir f5 pas faut faire gaffe au
fouet f4 qui peut être en prise six
cavaliers des quatre pattes
ouais ok le gère bien la mettre la tour
en a quatre et le kabyle peux pas trop
bouger parce qu'il ya f2 en l'air
toutefois la fouettent royal mais traque
un tueur à des découvertes
ouais mais quel échec
elle se trouve à tour ces trois j'aimais
bien elle veut mettre la pression est là
elle ne peut pas le prendre suis là j'ai
l'impression qu'ici mais tu vois les
ricains second le truc intéressant c'est
que c'est une semi gave de mon l'avez
peut-être fou des quatre essais ça elle
donne le pion mais t'as vu qu'elle est
la marque un vrai temps d'arrêt à la
donne et genre 10 secondes pour tout
vérifier
après elle a raison car a lieu cette
baisse est à il fait mal suis là seb il
colonisation égalisation et soleil tu as
fait mal il me fait un peu mal en se
remettant je pense que ton analyse
à la fin du 5 puis sein de dire en 3 + 1
le danger c'est que comme katia et jouer
quand même assez vite les ouvertures
ça peut être un peu plus un avantage de
3 + 1 je pense que c'était prémonitoire
après ça veut pas dire katia va gagner
mais je pense que c'est une cadence qui
la favorisent un peu plus que le simple
changement social
alors là tu fais quoi tu fais dame s'ils
en ont encaissé trois peut-être away tu
peux away parce que surpris ce
qu'avaient les baies 5 types de
classiques et car il prend des singles
oui hong kong
ça ça me dit quelque chose ouais j'ai un
personnage en énergie sa balle ultra de
théorique est ce qu'il ya pu y aurait
pas eu un petit coup de fil à ben laden
à la mi temps là non ça sent pas le deal
à vlad 6 thouars c'était magique ça sent
le coup de fil à vlad attends je vais
écrire robinson d'un premier saut
j'écris à vlad les mecs c'est pas mal
c'est ce qu'elle a fait
comment on descend cette fois alors le
message pour vlad c est ce que tu as eu
qu'à tirer le téléphone pour la tromper
on va voir ce qu'il répond je sais
qu'ils regardent le match parce qu'on en
a parlé tout à l'heure ensemble attend
n'y a pas souhaité y avait même des 5 et
choqués mais sains que c'était une bonne
ressource défensive des folies troqué
avec les blancs hélas là j'aime bien
avec 3 probablement les grands atouts et
dame prend france et trois rois f1 c'est
hors de question en salle pourquoi pas
et tu prends m6 ouais
après c'est mon répertoire avec les
blancs donc tu vois j'ai un peu le 5 il
y avait une tronche pas mal mais j'ai
pas d'investissement qui est peut-être à
mon tour j'ai eu deux histoires et là je
fais que mon jeu me battre à quel point
ce n'est pas tout ces quatre au caire et
blanc c'est possible bref il peut-être
et on réfute à sousse et quatre non
faussée 4 ça me paraît être hyper fort
c4 qui est des huit ça l'idée tous ces
noms c'est horrible au caire il faut
c'est canteloup prend comme point 7
moi je ramasse toutes les tours du
ramasse les deux tours et j'ai rien et
j'ai pas de contre les deux hommes font
17 pour pousser 4 c'est vraiment fort
vous ces quatre sets il veut aller taper
le plus bref cette en force mais
l'option de le voir voilà katia en
petite forme quand même parce que c'est
une sacrée bitzer quand elle est bien
ouais je sais mais il ya clairement du
répondant ce toi t'aurais la torah ça
fait mal
ok toi même tu as peut-être dams est ok
5 d'un problème c'est que des messages
de l'as grand roque après bon du coup je
suis d'un médecin ouais c'est le coup
que je pensais que tu allais proposé
d'être cavalli à vendre des quatre à
temps il s'est passé quoi cette non
c'est une tour je comprends pas non plus
il ya tout reprend 2,5 aussi d'ailleurs
un annonce un catamaran et avait dame
prend ses quatre ans et quatre non mais
là c'est par contre je pense que tout
est bien mais auquel elle ou la colonne
des points centraux de hockey haleine
par les blancs sont par ailleurs le roi
des trucs où ça lui réussit bien à
chaque fois même si là elle avait la
vigne il faut être encore précis avec
les blancs il ya un énorme avantage mais
les noirs on surfe a survécu au kenya
peut-être touré fut dame prend elle à
nanga valu six échecs intermédiaire bien
joué kherraz b 6 mai à peut-être tourbe
est un qui va arriver
ouais bon et elle peut se tromper mais
si tu parles en chantant en revanche
plongé le g8 en ligne de mire aussi
bonne défense
ça veut dire c'est toujours pas bien
mais le truc c'est que la dame a la bave
en fait d'un rêve cette tour f8 dames 6
tours 8
elle fait la technique de moore this way
points 5 et aura des huit aussi
incroyable à la super bien défendu
d'improviser vanille et si ce n'est
qu'elle vous tous tempo en plus ouais
c'est ça incroyable si elle donne
seulement l'échec le roi comment cette
insécurité qui joue pas du tout qu'elle
repart ans et 7 avec le roi est fou des
trois fous détroit revient à jouer
oui en fait maintenant elle commence à
se dire ok j'ai merdé jeu j'ai mon
avantage matériel s'est stabilisé leur
matériel froid elle va se prendre food
et qu'adam prend 1,2
j'ai pas aimé roy moi j'ai pas trop aimé
dame prend à deux j'aurais préféré food
et 4 direct pour maintenir l'initiative
tient parce que finalement la torah 8h
foot ou réfutent la dame en a deux et
pas super bien placé
ok j'ai un ensemble dans cette partie
les deux joueuses ont leur série de
coups quoi a bien joué tour g8
t'es juste un g5 un g6 voilà et la dame
revient
bon si ça suit le scénario du match
avantage autant la cnuced qui va gagner
la partie caillavet tour compte 17
avaient tous retombés 75 et dci avaient
tous répondu non il ya des trucs de
partie du quesnoy jouer avec alger 4 en
premier ou quoi mais attends là on en
est ou matériels ont annoncé qualité de
plus pour danielian normes et là se joue
avec des secondes tous les gosses
il ya tout comblé c'est tout le temps
d'ailleurs
ok ouais mais c'est hyper dur à jouer
avec avec les centièmes non mais elle
doivent finir avant oui bien sûr bien
sûr mais on lui avait fait croire que
cet automne trois de ses petits fils
c'est tout de suite qu'il prend une pour
cela il faut pas que ça la somme parce
que là tu peux être être ok mais le plus
grave là dedans c'est que c'est que 4 et
en plus elle prend l'avantagé là-dessus
clairement moralement là c'est dur c'est
que tu viens de prendre deux trois rôles
assez une série 3 0 pour catia et le
scénario des partis et pas forcément
différent du scénario de début de match
où elle dominait complètement parce que
je veux dire tu as l'impression qu'il ya
un truc qui s'est cassé et
elle continue à mieux jouer et u20
bresse en fait elle prend 3 0 de manière
assez crue est et faut pas que ça là des
règles parce que je pense que si elle
continue à jouer comme ça danielian
qu'elle continue à faire ce qu'elle fait
elle elle peut elle peut remonter la
juste de petits réglages à faire mais il
faut il faut le plus vite
ah bon j'espère bien partis quand ils
étaient tous là dessus mais j'ai
l'impression que là bizarrement c'est la
première karo kann qui avantagent mans
c'est là la salle allait un peu plus
chiante
les cavaliers sont bizarres et que mr
regardent eux voient que le h5 typique
qu'est ce que tu fais ta tâche sinon ça
marche je vais faire ici ce que j'essaie
3 et 7 mais plus grave serait cloué bon
t'es tu laisses tu fais le grand que tu
laisses gsm edge c'est ton g8 aux
grandes colonnes je pense que tu prends
f7 sur les sept classes et horrible ça
croque ou non mais ça tu vois c'est une
conséquence des deux parties précédentes
bien sûr bien sûr assez durs dans la
tatin là je sais vraiment pas ce que les
normes ou un ba oui peut-être qu'à
l'école soit ok peut-être c'est pas si
mais ces quatre maintenant à 3 bat le
fer ckt pas cavaler bep cap mais je
pensais pouvoir ces quatre bons à toute
façon le roi et un g8
oui non salée mais tu aurais pu être à
tord eu l'impression que ça allait
réfléchir un peu plus longues heures en
jouant à 3 tu vois ça ne va pas assez
vite
bon là ça se stabilise pasqua et jean
assice houphouët 4 très bien ça c'est on
va retomber dans cette causerie d'abord
c'est un homme très bien joué bon je
vois que ça discute sur la séparation
une femme nous échec si on en discutera
tout à l'heure bon ben là je fais f6 ou
h 6 h si j'adore et je force bien joué
dans tron c'est un sujet sur lequel il
ya beaucoup de divergences
même sur le ca de la part des savants
oui c'est un sujet qui dépasse le
clivage homme femme pour les opinions
c'est un sujet assez assez compliqué à
ces épineux et c'est difficile de savoir
qui a raison à l'it et on a chacun notre
opinion mais c'est difficile de savoir
qui a raison en réalité bon cette finale
là on l'a on l'attendait déjà vu pas mal
je me demande si katia aurait pas
intérêt juste faire [ __ ] en d5 et
faire annuler cette table est pas bon ça
joue encore oui mais enfin elle s'est
tellement fait dominer dans le dans le
rapport pas de matériel font cavalier
qui demande si elle a elle n'a pas
intérêt à cette année d'accord qu'on
sort là dessus ouais c'est à dire bon ok
c'était 5 c est ce qu il n'y a pas de
souci avec ces gars ne voit pas pour le
moment mais c'est peut-être ce qu'elle
vérifie genre de passe prendre un four
b3 pénible bah ouais sur ses 5 fautes et
3 ce cas peut-être un joli rc5 en fait
j'avais l'idée c'est cinq pions prend
entourant et foulée trois balles peut
être un geek si tu enlèves la tour je
fais le pion isolé ça reste grave fatale
joujou 10 et cérébrales pas physique va
pas tout à fait mais quand même une
question endurance aussi les âges je dis
ça c'est des âmes qui montrent une
question l'endurance il ya une question
de votre qu'on ait une semaine par mois
c'est pas pareil une semaine par mois
ouais mais bon j'ai mis du temps à
comprendre en fait mais n'empêche que
ces lois est important ouais alors après
à des sportives qui prennent des des
noyaux des traitements pourra régler ce
souci
mais après c'est vrai que c'est un
problème et qui capte pas danger pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas capté sur le coup j'ai
buggé la cab bizarre comme thaler à la
structure comme ça
l'a45 est très bien je peux pas gérer
ces cas tu as peut-être khalifa pourrait
changer maintenant
mais ça c'est bizarre aussi tour points
chauds bon après tu t'en foutais de la
colonnade genre et j'avais fait non plus
mais bon c'est 5 de cette semaine que tu
reviens ses cadres ouais ouais non c'est
vrai c'est pas bête non cette fois ci
c'est plutôt les blancs et tourcoing h1
c'était tellement bizarre après je pense
pas cela va mener à priori rien sur la
colonne jeu mais auquel vous sert besson
enfin les vrais avec les plans quand tu
joues ça parce que tu peux aussi refaire
tout rachat est sûre b5 du coup
peut-être prendre une fois est allé
chercher du tour a bien joué classé très
bien joué ça il ya la synchro
du coup b6 et une petite concession nous
en reste quand même extrêmement solide
et le faire j'ai quatre des cinq tours
h7 ou cavaliers 5 quelle chance et
qu'elle allait prendre va surtout quand
tour à schwyz où pranger 6e
elle a oublié le pion ouais et cavaliers
cette fougue 4 et tour v5 va revenir
c'est intéressant même si tu laisses des
5 tu peux dire que tu contrôles un peu
les cases noires sous charge mais est ce
que c'est ça il ya touria cavaliers
ci-dessus et sareh bayat ou rejet 5a où
là où il y avait tout récent 3 qu'elle a
du coup alors qu'elle a c'est fini tweet
magnifique
alors faire canal là c'était peut-être
c'est le ton se sont jamais insulaire
tasci miser sur une expression qu'il
faisait ce qui me faisait marrer dans ce
genre de cas il est oui cela tu n'étais
pas obligé de la perdre ça m'a toujours
fait rire ça t'es pas obligé de la
perdre genre tu avais quand même le
choix dans celle là tu avais pas
d'obligation alors elle défend encore un
petit peu avec le caravage me demander
s'il fallait faire pour congé si c'est
si c'était pas encore plus simple de la
chaîne n'a pas besoin pour le moment
non mais c'est souvent des questions que
je me pose c'est pour bien finir
qu'est ce que la vie peut-être cavaliers
f5 peu rodé der fourchette y avait
peut-être kf5 droit à machin pour g4
tu vois c'est peut-être moins simple à
gagner au final après ok non non le foot
lui je voulais faire après je me demande
ça aussi parce que je veux c'est qu'on
joue contre des mecs comme fil rouge
déjà où des mecs comme ça ils sont
tellement bons pour tarnac est quand ils
ont le cavalier que tu as toujours envie
de faire un live à avoir pour ces trois
points tu as toujours envie de faire le
plus précis possible parce que sinon les
mecs ils restent en vie et ils sont
chiants bon c'est pas clair maintenant
la donne et c'est cet accord très bien
mais on joue sur les secondes en cours
et le cavalier d'un hacker je pense
qu'elle aurait dû essayer de jouer a
fait 5 plutôt le pion à feu elle avait
pas mal d'occasions de le jouer en fait
f5
je suis un peu étonné qu'elle n'ait pas
fait ça commence à prendre forme
c'est dur de défendre il ya plus d'un
moins bon bon ah ça c'est très bien joué
comme ça le problème septembre dernier
elle aurait eu le temps de jouer f5 et
d'envoyer du contre je l'aurais
peut-être perdu quand même mais du coup
ça aurait été un peu plus déstabilisant
pour katia ouais ok on avait on a bien
compris le point faible de danielian
c'est quand il reste juste quelques
secondes elle n'est pas allée patrick i
ouais c'est ça elle refuse de passer par
position perdante pour tenter un dernier
spectacle
par contre ton visage et un petit peu
disparu de la cam
ouais en fait c'est vrai c'est pas le
visage qui a disparu est en baisse un
tout petit peu la casse
la terre un poil trop je suis trop en
fait ce qu'on est et pourquoi là c'est
parfait a été parfait alors on nous
montre qu'il y aura un prochain match ce
sera ce dimanche
le 26 matchs kosteniuk contre hatton
spire pierre mandelli sera chaud et toi
tu seras là mitropa cap
oui ces comptes a dit dimanche donc
dimanche contenait 25 26
alors on a un calendrier jusqu'à sa
fiche en dessous le 27 donc ce sera
lundi il y aura gouina contre croche et
le 10 mai et le et le et le 30 mai
drones à validons contre ce bague et ce
sera le dernier quart de finale donc
beaucoup de rendez vous à venir c'est
ben ouais des rendez-vous à foison j'ai
envie de dire aux querelles j'ai eu
cette position oui et donc là celle
inverse c'est la paire de fou pour pour
danielian et le fou cavaliers pour pour
catia
donc elle joue au cas donc c'est marrant
on va on va ré avoir le même truc voilà
reposer on va voir si elle joue aussi
bien venir à tout à l'heure les
cavaliers
c'est étonnant sur ce format avec le
temps qui ya des fous qui est pour davy
dessus alors c'est une petite concession
cette pastille à la trop grande et 8 et
prend à berne
et après on pourra peut-être même mettre
la dame en d4 pour gagner un temps sur
a7 suivant où est-ce que tu ferais pas
aussi g4 pour l'empêcher de cavalia le
ping de lattaquié je ferai tour 17 là tu
vois rapidos genre direct dur et fait
tourner ça je pense pour menacer tout
reprend beyssade bêtement je sais pas ce
que ça va aller mais ça ça me semblait
avoir une bonne tête à tour sur la
cession mais bon ça aussi mais juste
cavaliers vraiment ça venasque m la tour
b 8 et sur ouais moi j'aime bien et tu
fais peut-être tour de 7,1
ouais ok peut-être fait retour des 8
donner un pion et ça pue mois le prends
le temps ça a l'air d'être une bonne
stratégie
est ce qu'on mettrait pas un peu laurent
sécurité d'abord avec g3 roger de
l'année cette âme c'est s'être battu à
tours 17 direct ça c'est empêcher quand
même dame c'est ça reste avantage je
pense j'ai l'impression que tours 17 au
lieu de ces 4 mai paris oui parce que le
pion être obtenus en c3 avec des idées
quoi tu avais des trucs ça reste très
bien elle veut mettre un terme en 17
normalement ça devrait être ok ça pour
les j'ai bien travaillé ces structures
c'est exact structure en fait le 83 les
droits pour les noirettes 2003 et le
fait qu'ils aient le foot case blanche
man ray en septembre c'est plutôt la
pièce que tu peux échanger la bombe soit
tu veux un cavalier pour combiner les
attaques avec la dame son tube le fou de
cases noires sur la grande diagonale
pour faire dire que ça suffit pas bah
c'est compliqué peut-être même tu peux
échanger entre 4 et 12 tours 7
tata bonne structure avec avec b6 et
cède c'est compliqué pour les blancs de
jouer b45 salaire suffisant pour
l'analyste
bon il va forcément se passer toutes
façons de choses inhabituelles ici et là
on glisse j'ai l'impression que c'est
même peut-être plus plus risqués pour
les blancs du coup je pense même après
oui mais non mais là il doit essayer de
gagner des parties quand même et j'ai
cette bizarre moi je fais tour débute
j'ai l'impression qu'on y aille apple
elle joue peu de quoi agressif peut-être
qu'elle avoue qu'elle ait besoin
non mais je relis de la part des deux à
l'égout les deux mais j'essaye d'être un
peu on contrôle de faire ta tapas
d'escarmouches c'est toujours tout en
contrôle permanent est alors le tour des
7 c'était peut-être pas plus fort mais
tu as le choisissent comme ya le choix
entre un coup très agressif et un coût
plus sécurisant tu as l'impression
qu'elles ont des deux tendances avec
attend on peut pas rentrer la finale de
pions faire g5 créé un pion passé jean
roy e 4 bon j'ai cinq direct c'est là
même mettre laurent au 4 et jouets pour
bébés 4 c 5 gagne 1,5 et tu vois ce que
je veux dire jusqu alors oui ça là par
contre c'est que il faut garder un pion
à l'est le roi côtés de noms parce que
sinon il le problème du chiapas et
l'éloigner donc là je pense juste à
temps pour la seconde à l'an passé les
quatre ici des quatre bergers de cette
saga noire quel est le truc c'est que
peut-être tu dois essayer de jouer à 5
pour envoyer ton pions le plus loin mais
à cinq as bas il ya juste à 3 pts est à
et tu fais à 4 je veux bien
et c'est ça que tu as regardé mais ouais
à 5 à 4 c'est bien il faut que voilà il
faut que tu aies la solution d'aller
chercher de change à mes trois très
choqués les besson quitte les c6 c7
crois oui oui là c'est bon signe a tancé
pas si sûr à c'est pas sûr que ces
gagnants mais parce que tu viens
défendre tu viens défendre le 8 mai
maintenant je vais chercher ma forme et
je me battrai ces quatre là plutôt f4 je
force lors à partir et roi des cinq
oasis allée chercher les pions mais
ouais zhouqu dans les bras de son papa
7 mais tu t'en fiches est allé chercher
des pions à l'euro mais salem était
tellement retard noté complètement le
prend mal catch même origine c'est même
pas la peine
quels facteurs roi c6 r c'est sait bien
que pour revenir la donne est encore
d'intérêt à ce match oui bah là le roi
elle vient elle revient à un point est
plus que l'intérêt est ce que ça fait
quand tu prends un f6 quand même du coup
trois problèmes 6 force et b6 c'était
quand même bien devant oui ça bizarre
que katia sont rentrés cette finale de
purell pu encore qu'on a vu comment j'ai
cinq ai pas besoin
mais d'ailleurs souvent les finales
comme ça deux tours avec des équilibres
des tours de chant ouais non help us
elle l'a vraiment c'était à vue d'oeil
sa santé même si elles étaient nuls ça
sentait la finale tu as peut-être avec
un jeu chiant je vais aller nul mais ça
sent la finale où tu vas devoir galérer
ok ça ouais cette position là c'est sûr
laisse toujours les mêmes les mêmes
délires mais là c'est pas la variante
pillage l'avait cavaliers 5 7l cfl s'est
fait mal la magic mouse son coin par htc
gros avantage blanchisseurs étonnant
qu'elle assure ça oui parce que j'ai 6
je crois qu'il ya des parties de la sq
est maintenant très connu dans
l'ouverture
bizarre non non je crois que ça va aussi
deux concerts
mesdames mais trois noms mais blizzard
pour les noirs non de la wii
or tous incroyable incroyable alors ça
attention à 6 c'est fini si ces filles
de 25 c sur les faire céder tous ses
promotions incroyables 30 rencontres
séguin blanc en ligne et non en fait
c'est pas si évident j'avais regardé ce
que j'avais fait une vidéo pour montrer
cette variante la voile effet une
carrossée genre plus 120 +1 30 sur
l'ordi ouais ouais enfin bon ok c'est
mal mais tu sais pas perdu perdu par les
badges avec cette pièce de moins c'est
incroyable je crois que cette coutume
alors est-ce que c'était pas un mythe
clique alouette à jouer des 4 je sais
pas parce que des traces fait pas trop
sens là bas tu te dis que je compte le
souhaite cette fois mais voilà ils
menacent ou c3 est ce qu elle valoir
tu peux jouer à l'emploi ses membres ce
que tu parler du physique de la
différencie qu'entre les hommes les
femmes et où peut-être que c'est plus
dur
tu vois de tenir le coup d'essayer
maintenant ce que c'est physique 1 mais
attend une menace vraiment ces trois
dames font d'autres excuse moi oui c'est
très physique
bah qu'est ce que je vais faire tourner
en mai un truc que je vois pas - je
voulais parler d'accord tu voulais pas
je voulais juste me fera tomber un je
vais faire souvent déception cd il n'y a
pas de procéder avec dame pro f 6 tu
vois oui en tout cas je voulais pas
faire d'amd mais ça me paraît juste dit
quand on est une pièce de moi je voulais
jouer leur va-tout à fond kwame kwei le
nom mais là si les mois à reebok et
tranquille aux cavaliers g4 des revient
en effet trois cavaliers 5
non mais tu vas pas qu'on était
alexandre c5 ses 5 fautes et 3 à 3
c'est pour ça que je voulais m'embêtait
kg 4 en premier ou en france
ao question bon quelque chose nous dit
que c'est pas fini et cavaliers ou cinq
peut-être maintenant 30 rock je suis pas
histoire de faire dernière connerie
attendre ok cac valeo 5 la haye adam
prend d'un processus mais calais france
et 4 à me prends des quatre epr en d2 et
chaque vin rigaud et du salami avait
d'après f-cell très bien en c4 peut-être
parce que la leur apprendre à chis wes
que j'avais ce que je regardais ali
bacar h5n1 est tombé huit peut-être fief
tête courbée 8 tu peux quand même
mais tu sais quoi je sais même pas à
quel point les noirs sont encore mieux
parce qu'il peut aussi tout dans cette
partie si tu jouais cinq heures à
peut-être du cavalier e 4 qui arrive que
si tu prends ya le curé recettes qu'ils
tombent aux caisses et semant mal à loos
où vit un peu et voilà je pense ça va
aller comme j'aurais que j'aurais
commencé parfois f4 honnêtement c'est
parce que je n'aurais pas voulu remettre
le pion en le fou en gc ce qui dépend
qui défend mais bon
carayon 4k y prend ok tu as déjà qu'elle
prend 1,4 qui peut être qu'il y avait
quatre qui peut quand même être
intéressant faut être quatre intéressant
aussi
il trouve qu'elles échangent des pièces
dédiées sur deux avec moi et là qui
s'allument on va subir la caraïbes 4 me
paraît fort parce que tu veux tu être du
fou des six solutions qui capta tu
prends des cas tu t'en fiches sept
cavaliers aux 4 je prends le cap et je
fais deux cavaliers ds mais tu reviens
premier auquel tu peux faire tout
reprend 17 ici tu en prends 17,1 me
prends à 8 mois on récupère ta pièce
saab à hong kong au choix qui a encore
mieux mais d'un autre côté tu es moins
fort sans sou des trois espaces
intéressant mais là les blancs sont
savions je pense qu'on est surtout
francisco les belges et quatre balles et
noir contre j'ai l'impression qu'il est
inquiétant ça va se retourner de porte
c'est très bien oui oui non c'est
intéressant j'ai l'impression qu'il n'y
a pas eu de même quand les blancs on
retourne recommence à être mieux je sais
pas quel point ça était sous contrôle
c'est quand même d'avoir commencé par
damien comme ça tu mets le roi de la
tourache le monde et c'est
matériellement on en est où en réalité
égalité sécurité
c'est juste égalité on peut peut-être
faire juste fou ces six avec les blancs
et se dire que nul en réalité c'est déjà
très bien ce que je sais pas le roi le
roi rage de moi il me fait peur là un
petit peu je me dis un jour il ya et du
damage quatre tours tours première ok ça
repart trop bébé chan c'est une bonne
idée
- changer le quart de tour à cavaler
jégo devait arriver mais peut-être pas
si grave faire x 4 faut tenir la casse d
un russie pour pas formaté du couloir la
caisse copieux c'est hyper étrange comme
coût auquel j 4 ouais mais en zite comme
ça mais je comprends pas ce que font les
blancs en fait ouais tu sais pas quoi
faire cet échange et mettre le ranger
cette dame f6 et échanges tout meilleurs
temps du roi 3 contre la position à
laquelle on dort et on va encore avoir
une super semaine mais je pense que les
noirs sont mis
alors parce qu'il ya le roi qui arrivant
des classes par quoi ok elle gagne un
tempo elle gagne deux bonshommes plus de
temps ça va fourche étaient des amis
c'était un peu bizarre au site pas filer
avec le roi on prend on va chercher à 2
je suis soufflé un roi à 3 c3 c3 la très
important la saq reich auquel tu peux
leur faire à ces trois à celle à vue
elle veut faire et foutez trois là je
pense y avait tous les échanges de fous
sont bons ou faux c'est incompréhensible
on comprend vraiment rien mais il ya
plus de temps pour les noirs mais fou
c'est de fouler trois saisons ou comme
ça faisait quatre c4 c4 il ya deux
façons
3 je pense pas que ça il faut surtout
pas changer des fous mais il y aura
quand même temps c'est pas si sûr si
c'est passé au second plan et c'est bon
échec
ok demeurant geste est le point fort du
parti
voilà voilà voilà plus qu'étrange celle
là plus qu'étrange seb
qu'on est passé par tous les états
exactement ce qu'on dit ouais c'était
c'était quand même spécial la pièce qui
est donné au début de partie après les
blancs qui sont retrouvés mieux la
finale qui positionne break était égal
et katia qui a quand même joué pour
gagner puis après la finale elle était
dure par contre pas le roi ou s'ils ont
du roi
oui et la finale a été très bien joué
par les noirs elle a bien le finalement
le petit tour avec le roi c'était bien
joué pour gagner des tempos sur le fou
bon c'est à peu près sûr que elle s'est
renseignée toute façon la position
qu'elle avait avec les noirs dans cette
trempe au était juste une mauvaise donc
is a long way version avec tout à
l'heure c'était bien ce qu'elle fait non
non non c'était dégueulasse en fait elle
était super mal à nouveau c'est là où
intervient au début et puis après
qu'elle a fait une grosse et çà et là la
rouquine donc friterie sécurité c'était
important mais tu vois il a arrive mais
déjà avait trouvé cette position de
faire genre cavale yeux de ses
trois-quarts aile et j'ai trois
cavaliers h 50 à venir quatre cavaliers
detroit calvados vous visez la case de 5
moi j'aime bien aller en verre h5 mais
bon c'est oui parce que ce petit échange
le foot quasiment contraint cavaliers
tout cas ce genre là cavalier g3 ah oui
oui cavalli ashton kutcher mais c'est
enfin j'en ai joué beaucoup des
parcelles l'afp et ça c'est très typique
c'est un plat typique arméno typique le
teasing cali il s'appelle erin kelly je
crois avance que soit géorgien mais
c'est des genres de rave de gros
raviolis à la viande dont la pâte est un
peu tard et on apprend par tous comme
giroux guillon pologne oui bah ça x est
un peu dans tous les pays c'est très bon
très bon c'est bon non mais là les
blancs sont bien en fait à faire
cavalier h5
elle va choper le fou elle n'est pas
pressée à la rigueur cavaler poinçon
ça craque de partout
y'avait qu'à rallier des choses en fait
être un non je pense que je vais essayer
d'aller taper bessette je sais pas à
quel point ça ça marchait peut-être pas
du tout
ah ok non mais on va l'aborder france
hors de moi qu'on va maintenant tour sur
la troisième affaire tour 5 d'ailleurs
mais tous peuvent signaler sinon plus
que faire tour 3 tours 5
petit bois mais j'aurais eu la même
philosophie que toi en me disant que le
roi noir était faible et qu'il fallait
en faire un peu plus quoi mais en fait
elle montre tellement sa supériorité
dans les finales jusque là je savais
qu'un fonds de plus la position alors
chez un architecte mais kata qui
craquent beaucoup hein
bah ça va contre autre acquis les
savoirs et des trois peut-être au caire
m cavalier f4 quand même vous prend bien
qui est aussi ce qui est bien sûr que tu
ressors tx55 sert à rien de rentrer là
tu en a besoin elles faiblesse en russie
sont f4 caisse pas toujours si simple à
l'air bon mais bon tu faire f 4 f 5 qui
était de retour cette fois h et 4 h 400
cas tu veux prendre de l'espace toujours
prendre de l'espace donc attaques de
minorités l'autre côté mais normalement
en tout cas j'ai l'impression qu'il est
noir
après cette finale ne sera jamais facile
à gagner mais tu vas y tu as quand même
un pseudo contre je vois souvent sont
donc là je suis un être de bien jouer
elle veut faire d'écart alors elle
aurait dû peut-être allez-vous bombes
etc at elle va peut-être laissé sa red 5
vous prendre une fois de havas et ça va
tu peux prendre de six à quatre sites
crps et ont pu ainsi qu il y aura jamais
tour c4 parce que tu as
toujours aussi sont six en l'air et elle
et blanc sont longues et si elles
gagnent ça sera 3 0 je me demandais si
on peut essayer de jouer avec un casque
et tours b 6 tu sais quoi avec pour les
noirs pour essayer de jouer le blocus
base même des champions plus il se
voyait plus du tout là je vous vois tu
te prends quand même sinon bah oui et tu
laisses tu laisses mais je pense que ça
pourrait bien que laura clients c2 et
jouer les 3 mais c'est pas sûr là c'est
intéressant parce que si tu prenais
aussi sur échec qui avait 3 e set et
ensuite on précise 3e set sur tourcoing
existe en france et 3 elle a bien joué
là bas je sais pas avec les blancs à
quel point j'aimais bien ton s'éprend
fêté à 4 persos ouais là c'est bien ce
que je pense elle va faire raid 4 l
échange auquel j'aurais fait tomber deux
têtes est libre je sais pas tu faisais
wildcat tu laisses pendant ces trois
échanges 0 à 100 franchises salaire bien
les éclats quatre tours c'est 3 way ou
de l'échec par 3 2 je me suis planté
dans l'entourage de l'échec et tourelles
froid tout prend tout reprend et prendre
aussi ça restait père dont je pense mais
auquel a été obligé de faire tout point
réussie suspense
ouais et je fais tu ouvres ce1 échangés
en 2h37 bon ok pas 40 mais bon là elle
se garantit une finale imperdable
pierron mais tour des trois des cinq
je pense que le roi va réussir à rentrer
en jeu
erwan eux bref si tu laisses des cas tu
fais trop 63.6 peut-être ça défouraille
tous racistes gagnent en fait tu laisses
ouais mais tu fais tout race est
maintenant ouais ça suffit a oui parce
que là je fais des 5 es tu échanges et
ou renforcent si elle prend et sûrs en
fonction reste que je pensais pas de
temps pour les noirs les sous qui la
regardent des 50 bondé selon elle prend
le risque mais en fait c'est bien tous
riches et accroît aussi ça a l'air
complètement dénoue laroque maxis tous
respectent ça me rappelle un peu une
partie en effet l'une de tes parties
effet en vidéo mais sauf que toi il y
avait déjà grand âge cette émission qui
partait oui ouais mais katia qui joue
quand même pas très très bien là non non
là on peut enfin de manière très
objective
là on peut dire que damian joue mieux
que ça tout le match oui katla qui
laisse traîner quand même des petits dés
petite fille peau tactique
après ça m'inquiète un peu pour le
bullet atteint je la sens plus du tout
au dessus dans aucun compartiment du jeu
je l'attend dans la vie non je pense
qu'en bullet et la conception il va
falloir qu'elle qu'elle vous dit juste
ça veut tellement se retourne et lui
cherchait pas les filles de speech et on
n'a pas été de voir ça qu'on a oui ça
peut se retourner
ça peut se retourner très vite ça c'est
une pulsion voilà déjà eu d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure qui avait été plutôt bien
pour les blancs si je me rappelle bien
elle avait pu isoler la et sur les
essais la hausse des prix de 2 à la
faune ouais ok elle avait repris du
cavalier et de raser son tour à cannes
où il a pris du fou d'accord rien
packard a lieu cinq
soit tu peux reprendre en d3 à temps
mais la dame d un forcée du coup ouais
mais c'est dégueu du coup kg 4 et c'est
mal ok mais qu'at il prend des points
fondre au hockey attention ouais mais je
pense pas que c'était prévu un mail à
n'y a pas juste un d'amd cette fois
justice au pire j'aurai toujours fois
fuite pour les noirs ou g6 ou cavaliers
h5 fin j'aurais même pas mal de mes fois
fuite pierre du pirin est bon il ya
peut-être mieux il ya peut-être des
coups comme d'hab bsi soit plus
ambitieux mais mais bon après mais cette
structure avec détroit isolés contre des
cinq isolé en général ça vous arrange
plutôt le pion détroit qui tient la case
de tête et il permet d'avoir une
question d'éclatement général la pièce
ont éclaté entre les deux entre les deux
pions mais d'un autre côté à la
structure des pechos du repas ou fumer
en fait le plein de 3 difficilement mais
à plomber 3 qui est un peu et mais là
effectivement on si peu et auradou 2 3
c'est quoi l'idée surtout f4 ou f4 l'idc
damas est qui a valu un cavalier fouet
f4 c'est quand même le coup que tu as
envie de jouer de base un make-up
sillage son fou prend qui a échangé
trois vous prend et comprend des cartes
à la fin et je rentre on le 2
donc faut f4 pas possible probablement l
entrée dans les calculs aider leurs
parents à f3
quidam à saint-albert non kelvin k veut
faire cavalier 5
ok centralisation c'est très fort en
fait ce que tu menaces fou prend des
cartes ias b2 qui traînent en plus des
deux qui traînerait bon surtout qu'on
les options sont peints avec de la tâche
et qui prend g7 qui peut rodez et je
pense sur dame prend b2 on peut même à
l'idée de jouer des quatre pour couper
la dame est attaqué comme des barbares
la très bonne chance pratique que
j'aurais fait des quatre perso je pense
alors je vois que vous êtes la même
question est posée depuis tout à l'heure
rapidos bas vous initier annonce coup
les deux peut-être plus que possible on
aurait parlé ce matin par hier mais
techniquement ce matin au quai des
cathos la carac toujours un bon truc
possible et c'est plus ou moins ce que
j'avais vu ses tours 6 avec les blancs
mais je vois là y'a plus on prend un f5
mais est ce qu'on peut faire cavalier h
6 échecs et dames c'est cette non ça va
pas donné grand chose
cette tour c'est un du coup ouais
activer des pièces bon jour pour faire
tourner cette en fait il n'ya pas
cavalier ou 4 6 4
il n'y a pas été aussi l'addition 4
tours f8 bon logique tour ses 7 ans
kevin disons je suis gourmand je fais
dame prend b3 est ce qu'il ya vraiment
une menace pour les blancs bas en cet
automne a demandé de le gérer et tu veux
faire droit à sa suite menacé le
cavalier quand ils sont battus prendre
trois étudiants c'est ça c'est
exactement ça mais cavalli 2,7 et
tourcoing 26 ya pas non tu te sens adam
g 5 personnes pour suroît je suis ta
voire d'un match 6 à attaquer la tour
mouais on l'envoie chez de ces dernières
minutes bon elle commence à ramener ça
me fait un peu peur j'ai cinq dont on
parlait ça me fait un peu peur pour les
noms en plaçant le truc hors de contrôle
qu'elle allait en train de dire t'as
rien donc j'en vois le pion mois mais ce
qui me paraît un peu près ça marche ça
marche pas l'action quelque chose pour
les blancs mais on trouve pas moyen
cavally h6 peut-être trois j'essaie de
cavaliers f5 déjà à minima mais moi je
suis d'arachide meilleurs atours g8
non mais j'ai l'impression qu'ici
j'ai passé à quelque chose à regarder
damage 6 mai on a juste pris la récupère
du temps je pense qu'elle allait
peut-être elle avait peut-être froid je
suis très content d'eux non non il ya
trop à huy ha vu signifier g6 pas mal en
fait 16 4 blocs un peu la diagonale du
fou c'est un énorme m il bougeait si ce
qui intéressant tu prends la propriété
de la grande diagonale en premier du
coup on ne sait pas ou alors elle va
transformer en stage les délicates et c3
ou détroit est transformé en fait c'est
désolant des âmes elle va faire des
études mendes classique on appelle cela
en fait voilà sur cavaliers des caps
dessous de 2 dans des haies ou amoureux
de deux sens alors dites yat monde se
sentait pas bien
on dit qu'il reste deux parties alors
dans cette cadence ans c'est peut-être
la dernière parce qu'il reste quatre
minutes 40 ans trois plus un bon écrit
que la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on va
avoir des bulles est super intéressant
enfin bon en tout cas un début de bullet
man ça reste intéressant tout le moins
en tout cas jusqu'aux cinq dernières
minutes ça m'étonnerait qu'il ya un gros
écart est quelqu'un gagne rarement 5 060
ouais ça aurait pas ce à quoi sinon à se
décourager en septième titre le pion des
quatre très très bien
en ouvrant la colonne s'est du coup il
est pressurisé un peu c'est le c'est
compliqué de jouer ces trois j'aime bien
j'aime bien la position
normalement les blanches bataille à la
fête est que le son soit plus en quatre
ans soit pas en quête c'est pas des
aides d'état pas trop le choix un tu
dois envoyer que d'envoyer un bout d'un
moment
mais je foutais un peu maintenant
médecine américaine qui peut revenir
vers des cinq après c'est horrible dès
lors son émotion je sais pas pourquoi
mais à chaque fois que je vois des
changes de la hollandaise
enfin avec les blancs là le f4 en
premier ils ont toujours des poubelles
alors je sais ni pourquoi ni comment
enfin je sais pas après ça pas une
réputation malabo non mais j'ai en fait
quand des mecs te font des câpres f5
avec les noirs et arabes sont qu'ils ont
des positions plus ou moins qu à oui tu
as ajout bon des fois tu gagnes le père
match mais en fait j'ai un truc quand tu
commences paraître 4 avec les plantes
mais tu sais de quoi il ya des positions
c'est d'avoir le temps non ted parce que
l'autre doivent faire le coup d'abord
two way possible et ça donne l'info par
après il joue par exemple le 4 c 5
pouces et 3,5 c 4 oui bien sûr mais
aussi gérer compagnie s'est en fait je
marque à couleurs inversées et aura
l'impression je relaie les sicilienne à
l'envers et machin mais déjà l'échiquier
exactement pareil les gens me demandent
la nage d'or si tu changes les couleurs
tu veux la même position tu te mets avec
les blancs ça paraît complètement fou
pour les blancs fait ça ces femmes
il va y en a fait tu jouerais jamais à 3
ah oui oui bien sûr si tu as les blancs
bah oui mais tu vois du coup la
perception te fait jouer un peu
différemment mais je pense que childress
qu'est ce que c'est ça la raison pour
laquelle le f4 dans une déposition
pourris ou est ce que c'est parce que du
coup tu étais en action le d'être en
réaction j'en sais rien tu vois mais
c'est pour dire juste que cette
hollandaise en premier c'est c'est à ces
poupées lisant bon après là c'est pas si
mal ce qu'elle a fait c'est un site
arrive à passer la dame est le cavalier
f3 en d3 pari fou pour la tamise
bloqueurs tu as quand même un bon centre
tu va préparer ce choc faire de bien on
pèche québec est l'âme j'ai trois
studios et f5 un salaire de
de cette boue regroupement hockey bien
je pars par le clouage bon je sais pas
je fais les deux pour les blancs
clairement les pièces blanches ont
extrêmement bien quand tu peux même
faire le plan avait que cinq cavaliers h
2 kg 4 si tu veux ok ça c'est pas mal on
tente un peu dommage en effet eu cinq
cas et ses quatre fous c'est un jeu
renfermé le fou pour attaquer depuis ont
des cartes en fait ça vaut ce que ça
vaut après il est blanc a joué les coups
comme b3 par exemple du coup était bien
un peu plus loin trois espaces igor
judge et rondes auxquelles a pris pour
faire 5 sûrement mais du coup à la pub
fou des deux qui prend 1,6 j'ai
l'impression qu'il va manquer ce fou ou
alors il vous sert aux 5 et attaqué des
quatre peut-être gagner des casses en
france avec damas de uturoa 4 bon écoute
c'est bien la longue cavale et prend des
caps mais peut-être prendre un droit
tour des huit c3 c'est un super bon mais
il y aura toujours des petits cavaliers
pour le six majeur auquel a dans son
coeur menace prise en d2 donc d4 défend
hockey fait retour des 8es c'est froid
et et bk bien joué en fait parce que tu
as pu le faire depuis cinq ans mais
c'est compliqué l'un à cinq simples en
coupe faim désespérée face est un peu un
coup de dents mon sens il donne des 5 ok
elle crée une menace en c3 il faut
prouver que tu peux je crois que le
cahier des cas tu arrives pas le choper
à la fin
malheureusement c'est pas s'est passé
de hockey les échanges de pièces
devraient être une bonne idée pour les
blancs puis ce qu'ils en avaient le
moins injuste
ouais maintenant dame du cap où c'est
toi la qualifier de grand baie car oui
il faut prendre b4
peut-être qu'ils éprouvent 6 où tour à
quatre mois aura qu'un seul letchis
poésie du maniaque et prend des huit là
mais prend à rêver sa part est hyper
dangereux pour les noirs parce que leur
prime à l'art d'être complètement bon en
plus ça joue sur un côté de l'échiquier
bon cela ça favorise le chaos en effet
repoussé cinq ans vitesse est fou aux 7
pour bloquer pour colmater un peu les
cases mais mais pour le moins n'y arrive
pas parce que là qui a valu à 48,8 fou
j'ai un peut n'être ni à tom price est
les deux multi d'un v8 way home elle
tombe non 1,3 yable ah ouais non c'est
abusé d'un 81.5 se définit donc ça fait
8 8 seb je suis dégoûté ça fait 8 8 et
c'était la dernière c'était la der de la
cadence et ça tourne à 8 8 mai à
mais incroyable incroyable on peut
tomber à elle est tombée dans la no
moment où c'était s'était finie je vois
que je mesurais comme je t'avais dit
quand nous aurons baisse j'ai plus de
mire ouais bah écoute un c'est la vie
qu'est-ce que je laissais d'allumer
talent pourrait si ça c'est pas dire s
il reste une demi heure parce que je
pense je pense qu'on va tenir comme ça
ouais au caire ont fait une pause du
coup c'est un ouais on va refaire une
pause moi je vais remettre je vais
remettre la petite page de pub et on va
repartir et on va repartir sur une pause
de qualité avant avant les bullet 7 qui
vont être qu'ils vont être complètement
fou
bah ouais je pense que pour bien
s'exprimer du coup ouais ouais je pense
que je tremblais je m'en fous je te
cache pas que je suis un peu ça c'est un
peu le marathon j'ai pas à quel point je
serais fou fou mais on va on va tenter
le mieux ok on va tenter le mieux du
continent sont tous merci seb
merci à tout de suite je lance la pub
[Musique]
les mecs je suis de retour ça va
probablement très bientôt arriver la
pause se termine on va partir on va
partir pour les bullet qui vont être à
mon avis assez assez intéressant
puisqu'il ya eu 8 8 et ça ne peut pas
être plus serré le match risque de
reprendre d'une seconde à l'autre et on
voit seb qui revient savez de retour
pour la dernière ligne droite donc sa
place à être le grand moment du match
ouais ça va être chaud mais là c'est
chaud là là c'est le chaulage suis
excité c'est ben ça y est ça commence
ouais là on est à huit 8 on est bien
c'était le hors d'oeuvre et là on
attaque le plat principal
comme quoi c'est bien l'importance du
bullet on en parlera jamais assez aux
échecs
ouais bah oui cette annonce faire les
gens pensent que ça se décide en cinq
minutes en 3 buts en partie longue et en
fait tout se décide en bullet c'est
vraiment la cadence si tu veux qu'ils
qui décide tout quoi c'est là qu'à
l'institut
ouais bon tu vaux qui a écoute je vois
katia parce que lé dominé tout le match
elle gagne que dans les ait et donc
voilà c'est parti c'est le cavaliere
trois directs web en commentaire jusqu'à
f3 difficilement mais la couche meilleur
elle va alors ac alors simple qu'est ce
que tu penses 75 des cinq ici normal on
est loin des 6 e cavaler dans la crise
en france sont très bien très bien joué
donc cavalier ces trois dames b3
peut-être c'est pour s'en prendre aux
pions b sat et des symptômes on en parle
on commence à le faire qui avait levé 5
ne le sait pas assiste peut-être voilà
bien alors dame b tremblement qui
retarde à cause de cas et c'est ça qu'on
imagine scène change pas ok on me fout
en justice peut-on sera ok car il ya
quatre ans qu'elle veut aller jusqu'à
plutôt une bonne chose attaques des
saintes au passage mon attention et elle
veut prendre le pion des le foot j'aime
ça j'aime pas ta pas des cas parce que
ça les projets de b2 tréfonds hockey à
l'époque et dames v6 pas mal on va faire
tourner ses huit échange les dames c'est
bon vous leurrez change pas et change
pas le foot gay devait être maître de
l'échiquier seb est tombé huit ok pas
mal le cavalier ressent vert à 3 sur
vous pour les cavaliers
un médecin qualifié pour ces 6èmes sur
ses six combats si elle n'a pas vu l a
pas vu et maintenant la tour arrive sur
ses seins à c'est assez mal bon ça va
savoir foissac soutien à cette satire
pas du tout ça les sensations c'est à
dire pas du tout au tout en 24 36 bon
allez des cavaliers et cavalières une
fourchette évoquée par m
ok elle voulait juste attendre bonjour à
8 et elf ou qui revient en c6
complètement fou c'est cette poussée
seul cavalier f17 dangereux ok mais roy
g2 est ce que le roi va monter mais
y'aura f5
ouais c'est vrai quoi ouais c'est vrai
bon 8 ça résiste mais les fous qu'on se
rend bien compte
ouais mais ça résiste vieux prennent
alors le pouvoir revenir en b3 sur échec
qui va empêcher fois roy aussi ça laisse
moi aussi je suis un peu étonné mais roy
de son ouais mais le roi qui fait quand
même l'effort ouais il va y avoir au
bacon and beer demander sa tv 8 bat
c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini et on
n'y en avait pas vu le fou prend 17 b 8
là c'est une ouverture cas
catastrophique pour la joueuse
arménienne qui réussit pas finalement
c'est ce dont tu avais peur c'est bon
elle réussit pas à tenir la cadence dans
l'ouverture et changements de plans côté
noir ça c'est pas terrible ça pour les
pour les noirs way down aussi ça va ça
va ouais si c'est ou beckett et dessins
que ça on va espérer pour la joaillerie
n3f devrait ben moi j'aime bien les
blancs donc c'est plutôt bon mais je
crois que c'est comme celui en cours et
de carhaix lieu de les rendre au gic
apte à y aller il faut y aller
le kaki par an ces cinq est-ce qu'on
peut égaler un petit coup de bk tu étais
un jour fou g5 histoire d'attaquer le
fou l'appareil est là c'est qu'elle
prend 17 qu'elle prend 17 c'est qui
oh la la c'est une tour qui sait une
tour qui part la cèbe parfait à l'épaule
à finir c'est ben ouais faut
complètement la fine y aller faut bien
dire jouer on va faire damer b3 dam des
trois je veux dire on va échanger tout
ça je m'attendais mais maintient de 6
prend un tour prend ses huit dames ces
deux pour rien là bravo tranquille
allait elle a montré qui était le patron
car la f3 de retour alors évidemment
alors haussé alors il va il va falloir
je vais peut-être un fouet f5 cavaliers
se pressent à quinze jours du système de
londres a versé donc et ça change tout
c'est pas pareil ouais non il faut être
solide pour le moins le champion des
claps et il faut il faut toujours bien
tenir ce fou de cases blanches là le
tenir en respect avec la chaîne de pions
seb lâche 4,2 et gk nous et il va y
avoir peut-être alors qu à rien je sais
qu'à six heures ça va s'arrêter mais il
ya le foot 7 qui va tomber et le fou en
f4 qui va être maître des cases noires
e3 ça va faire un système de londres non
il faut juste pas donné de questions car
et du club pourrait vite
ok mais va y avoir trois dames p2 damas
3e du cot ouais c'est vrai c'est le
dirigent tranquillement
c'est vrai qu'elle aurait dû venir en
catalan alors comment est ce que les
blancs vont gérer ça ils vont jouer avec
quatre peut-être un jour pour percer f5
dernière très bien joué bon en fait
j'aime pas du tout a bien joué mais
toujours aussi ses soutiens et qu'il
prend des cinq lions prend fou prend il
ya le curieux qui tombe à la fin
ouais donc elle fait même des sons c'est
un ouais mais elle reste très bien cet
os ou alors ça alors je comprends pas
pourquoi là elle est rentrée la loi
récente mais bon si on sont un peu
friable qui ont des cartes un peu
friable tour e
le choix très étonnant de la part de
katia self de rentrer dans ce jeu vous
prendrez 6 échange massif lecavalier d
ici c'était pas si passifs alors mais tu
paries sur télé d'options centraux pas
mal le sujet de tir un peu comme tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas la peur de fou mais
quand même cavalier avec a toujours
dangereux kaki venir vers 6hoo habsheim
bien joué elle couvre deux questions ne
peut jouer qu'à valider cinq mois
qu'elle ait 5 avec les blancs seb 70
titien auquel veut la jouer tranquille
des 4 alors bon il ya quand même des
problèmes à résoudre
et ben si c'est pas mal on a regardé le
footsie s'est soudé ce n'est trois assez
bien draps on gagne des quatre enfants
ce qui va gagner le pion mais attention
tu veux aussi aller au combat alors le
plus réussi ce qui va pouvoir être
contrôlé après tout reprend des 4 6 3 et
fuite c'est 3 800 tranquille le roi va
venir le contrôler je trouve que le jeu
de quartier a été assez faible dans
cette partie fou prend des six m'a paru
quand même une décision plus qu'étrange
pour beats et amener db5 bien joué quand
même on affaiblit dh alors il peut
tenter eux six tours v8 maths alors il
faut prendre soin du wef rang des cinq
échecs passe ça passe à elin à elle
c'est moche après tous ces matches c'est
ben ok ben on va voir que sa façon ouais
c'est finalement tu as raison a cédé
partie qui se joue plus sûr sûr sûr une
sur une erreur sur une gaffe que que sur
une domination stratégique pour le
moment donc katia qui a repris
l'aventage ça me fait un petit point sur
le timer il reste 23 minutes de jeu
donc tout reste encore à faire il ya
qu'un point d'écart pour le moment donc
faux b4 bien jouer encore pendant des
semaines de la dame
par son courage parfois de les blancs
qui vont aller rauque et le petit
puristes de la classique on n'a pas su
s'adapter à cette fois un peu nouveau
par rapport à tout à l'heure et la
position est plutôt pas mal pour les
blancs dam des deux je pense c'est vrai
que le roi noir on a du mal à voir où il
va alors effet petit rock mes meilleures
structures pour les blancs et c'est là
où tu dois envoyer acheta tâche son
entourage 3
un petit peu mais tour bien tombé 115
tours b 5 tours h5 peut être une idée
vraiment violente d'ailleurs tour b5 ici
est une option à peut-être forcée pas
mal f5 f5 bien joué je pense qu'il faut
il faut empêcher à 7 ou redevenir alès
la tour partira jamais faux projet six
sous projets si c'est fou quand je serai
prête à m'aider à gagner
elle n'a pas vu c'est raté allez tu fais
tout racheter quand même ou pas ah ouais
bien sûr
non non il ya des objets 4,406 parce que
cavalier de katsina musicale série
entourage trois noms cavaliers à venir
est là j'avais peut-être tour g3a mais
je perde une telle allure de raie pour
vous pour angers 6
normal c'est tellement de choix allez la
tourache trois tours à trois mois la
torah je crois maintenant moi je suis de
force et sa plus dure indépendant pour
les noirs mais pas s'ils sont attaqués
comme elle menace ce tour h3 peut-être à
nouveau rage trois dames g6 pour leur
maintien
ok ça ramasse un pion il va falloir
faire un petit peu attention mac du
couloir quand même ses problèmes avec la
taupe qui coulissent vers troisième tous
ces huit à bien s'en prendre aux pions
ces trois à quatre à quatre l'idée sur
fou prend 1,4 c'est de prendre à 6 on
imagine en tout cas avec tango sur le
foot on attaque le fou qui repart en c6
et du coup là ils n'auront pas de menace
elle pour ça fait un peu peur la leur
est demandé de bien jouer à l'un des
deux très bien vu mais damas des dames 1
am et on prend ces quatre et des sacs et
des cinq meirieu 5 et 26 ou la wii la
dame des cas très bien vu ok on peut pas
prendre le 6 malheureusement ça va deux
fois sur nul et une proposition est
acceptée puisque 10 secondes devant la
pendule donc on voit dans ces bulles est
que en réalité c'est les blancs qui
domine à toutes les parties pour le
moment donc c'est un peu comme un
service au tennis je dirais seb la bd
blanc ok changement complet de stratégie
elle a vu qu'elle est un peu du mal dans
les structures slave sur le déplorer
thibault
une mouette indienne super théorique la
fameuse variantes qui à mon avis est
beaucoup plus facile à jouer en bullet
avec les blancs avec les blancs
attention pas souhaité y aurait des six
ok ça se stabilise
on va vouloir android u14f 4,5 peut-être
avec les blancs fut f4 aussi jouable
pour jouer contre le pion des 6 et
contre attaques de l'autre côté avec b5
bekkat sava parent d'élève a laissé peu
décalé chaque année ça va y aller il va
falloir organiser donc pour les noirs la
contre attaque allèles dame seb les bic
app store ou c4 c4 cavalli ses stocks
ces quatre des cinq thématiques dans les
structures benoni pour venir prendre la
case d3 l'a complètement structure
benoni ici normalement tu fais eux sont
payés à 5 h quatre cavaliers f6 alors
j'ai l'impression que j'ai plus apprécié
ta manière de jouer avec les noirs parce
que là j'ai l'impression quand même
qu'elle laisse un peu les blancs
s'installer sur l'échiquier a aussi ça
c'est chiant ouais auxonne same way
alors le fou bessette qui va la vivre ça
c'est vrai bon tu peux jouer dès ce
mercato soit 6 des trucs comme ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est pour faire
attention au fond des cinq communes se
tient les 5 peut être faible et aussi
pourquoi pas un plan biz argent roi est
lui 3e set colmater ramener la tour a
chuté à te faire une menace et d une
attaque de match je sais qu'en partie
longue ce serait un peu bizarre ok j'ai
un autre pensée je fous et 6,3 g 7 tours
à je suis prêt à les noter
oui c'est peut-être plus propre mais tu
vois j'aurais switcher sont des deux
ânes on ne peut pas tout de suite
pourquoi alors pas bien bref 5 qui s est
pas mal aussi mais pas mauvais mais je
trouve que c'est dommage que que
danielian n'est pas switcher le jeu
allait droit c'est quand même du bullet
ont beau char est très très très
choquant même genre pressé comme un pion
ses deux oreilles mais le pur en c2 il
va mourir
c'est pas fou mais à tam et d'apprendre
des cinq prêts à notre tour si vite la
france évite à me prends des cinq bien
joué bon elle prend son envol la ouais
c'est dur ça fait plus de et je pense
vraiment que daniela c'est un manque
d'expérience en bullet parce qu'on dû
l'être a envoyé des tours sur un roi ça
fait toujours peur c'est ben ouais c'est
possible allez bon petit a là encore
j'aimerais avec les noirs a joué que 6 3
avant c'est une petite vente avec les
blancs j'ai vu des grands maîtres jouer
ça aussi dernièrement games elle a
raison faut développer des pièces pas
perdre de temps c'est bien toujours à 50
secondes rauque et très vite toute façon
elle a le temps il ya que deux points
d'écart
il reste 15 minutes 7,10 à qui tu as
joué rattrapable oui oui 2e cat
les plans classique attention à cavaler
h 54 pour jouer c'est 4 6 4 alors elle
prend il va y avoir prise en lui cet
intermédiaire échange massif et elle
reprend du cavalier prises ou prou
simple sapiens est way et on n'a pas le
temps de faire fou prendre cavaliers 5
et de rentrer sur la 7e il y aura tour
des huit je peux jouer dam des trois
essais de contrôle est rentré en
septième ou comme ça des qui a changé
détour garder le contrôle de la colonne
bien joué qu'elle et ses systèmes de 4
tab à 4 mai a été cité la question que
je me pose est aussi dangereux trois
sont ok bon salaire égal c'est
complètement égal après on a déjà vu
mais la présence de dames cavaliers ça
va être
danielian mettre un peu de pression mais
c'est bien joué très bien joué il faut
vite enlevé leroy arrivé comme ça
possible alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sur l'a57 elle s'en fiche totalement
sauf qu'elle passe gk3 g3 pour vite se
décourager un pourquoi pas s'écarter
affinant qui attaquent halal dame h 4 h
5 elle veut essayer de se mettre un peu
la pression sur le roi noir mais il ya
un moment difficile à 4 a toujours eu
une malle dans cette position là à
trouver un plan a trouvé un coup elle a
toujours eu du mal à rien faire
d'ailleurs elle prend du temps ouais je
pense qu'europe 1 nul cavalier e 5
peut-être ici oui et puis a dû d'amd
82.5 genre la date des huit apprend à 5
mais attention à la contre attaque avec
dom hum hum cas ce qui se joue manas
cavalia fuite
on a là c'est incroyable attendais pas
car elle annule avec cavalli et si ce
n'est le vote pas car il ya fisc a valu
huit dames
et 6,6 soit meilleur hockey dames 8
peut-être malin et damas fuite et
chamakh
nous avons très bien joué non quoi
l'amour avec m6 m'attendais mais c'est
incroyable la loupe m'attendre mais
j'avais pas vu non plus waouh
allez tu l'as vu ça y est la bonne donc
elle revient à un point et c'est
vraiment ses positions là qu'il faut
qu'elle cherche à obtenir cette katia
qui a vraiment du mal à trouver un plan
est peut-être b 5 à 5 elle s'affaiblit
tout seul finalement complètement
complètement les toute façon moi je sais
danser position là le tandem dame cavale
et profitent souvent au blanc sur la
majorité de pions et en général les
attaques
c'est plutôt savoir parce qu'il est noir
on faisait donc cette fois ci avec les
noirs elle a réussi à neutraliser le
problème du fou du fian kétou vous êtes
vraiment des problèmes et dames 17 je
pense que vu la physionomie du match
c'est un très bon coup sébastien elle a
intérêt à jouer plus tranquille et je
dessine alpes et nord c'est plutôt bien
joué mais le cavaliere vélo neuf capes
alors elle empêche food et 6 7 5 et on
peut toujours hors parti rend elle va
prendre une pièce c'est sûr ouais
ah non je voulais ils ont fait mentir
mais le faut être quatre bien placé n'y
a pas pour but auquel va jouer avec son
tandem de pioncer vite pour des visites
et si c'est un peu je pense que les
joueurs sont pas mal mais j'ai
l'impression que ces finales avec des
plantes plus clair c'est peut-être ça
favorise pas à catllar meja paraît que
c'est moins pire pour elle que ces
finales avec où il faut un peu attendre
s'asseoir comme on disait tout à l'heure
quand m6 ici simplement g6 paria 5 à 5 à
4 et aussi des f 16 go en europe
pour faire bref sets 3-6 c'est clair
c'est clair comme de l'eau de roche h4
prendre l'espace airwave cet art on
arrive à être jouée h5 et geci souhaite
qu'elle sait très bien jouer une
nouvelle fois l'impression que les noirs
et et tu perds peine que ça
qui avait lieu 3g 5 qui avalait h 4g
cinq cavaliers h sissonne tu prends un
g5 des rois g61 g62 et voilà
l'égalisation qui arrive et ça va être
très très bien à l'écran g5 un g6 mais
katia qui arrive vraiment à elle n'a
aucune conviction dans ses positions tu
vois c'est ça le point elle a pas de
plan ça se voit ouais mais même si elle
fait pas forcément des mauvais coups ya
pas de liant dans ses coups il n'y a pas
de tu vois c'est mou quoi allez faut pas
craquer c'est quand même assez facile
pour huit mois on tue ca mont des cats a
avalé des cinq attention qui risque
d'être 5
on amène nos cavaliers sont inouïs ont
réussi à le toucher la case de 4 avec le
cavalier doit tous prendre donc ça va
arriver maxis
ouais bon sens est noire et 44
fourchette ou trois tours de papa le
plus efficace mais ça boguey mais ça
doit gagner sans trop de souci il faut
quand même le temps ça va en plus normal
de gagner tranquille il faut quand même
faire attention jusqu'au bout whitelock
s complique un peu la vie des centrales
et des trois ya paillassou recherche
donc des trois ans maintenant et ça
passe là ça va finir la partie et on est
arrosé par tous égalisation il reste
onze minutes ça va être chaud ça va être
chaud à changement complet des 4 g 6 mai
katia qui est vraiment pas qui est
vraiment pas à son top aujourd'hui sable
quand même faut faut le souligner je
suis d'accord là on l'a on l'a connu on
l'a connu beaucoup plus tranchante dans
le petit jeu tactique alors tout à
l'heure ce lui a bien réussi cet automne
mais bon on peut se permettre de tout
faire voilà alors été changée ce qu'est
la fedom b3 tout à l'heure à voile à ce
sujet 5e c'est l'autre coup tu veux
faire d'amis autour des 1 aussi c'est
une option changé d'âme et je pense que
c'est une très bonne décision de la part
de danielian une nouvelle fois d'avoir
rentré dans cette finale peut-être un
petit coup comme h3 pour je le fous ou
trois ici tranquillement le 6 juillet
vous ici ou alors j'aime pas en fait
parce que la tour est ce qu'elle va
vraiment offrir une plus value peut-être
juste horrible et si c'était le couple
tu voulais jouer en plus donc ouais
ouais tu pouvais pas faire fouiller
quatre fous trois causes de cahiers g4
éventuellement et a finalement les fous
qui ferment et c'est vrai que tour des
six avait la tête d'un bon coup et
finalement cette tour était pas si bien
placé katia qui l' a le dessus elle est
mieux au temps elle a 30 secondes de
plus je pense être que c'est un moment
très important dans le match pour katia
elle doit gagner cette partie
elle doit absolument gagner cette partie
arrêter l'hémorragie des défaites déjà
premièrement est finalement tiré profit
de son bon retour de service et là on
voit la puissance de la peur de faut
bien jouer ça horrible
ouais le fou qui revit et la 15e bien
jouer well échange les pions 2.5 ça
libère un petit peu et on va essayer de
faire mieux ici qu'à relief de j'aime
bien elle veut jouer cavalier des trois
échecs peut-être cette attention
ouais mais roi des cas peut-être qu'à
relief 4 ok il y avait aussi b4 qui
était intéressant pour tenter la
fourchette
ok ça c'est bien c'est gagner en fait
n'en attend rien vous êtes comprend 25
il n'est pas champion prend 4 car il
prend 1 6 3 5 4
on évalue ces cinq étaient fondées
jouais je pense avoir pris aussi c'est
la finale hommes opposés mais là il va y
avoir droit f5 à l'appel du christ et 5
il faut trouver une bonne case pour le
fou noir peut-être le temps on regarde
le temps ouais 18 secondes contre 39
ça va être très dur à l'école dit
pourquoi pas jouer fou aux 5 et faire
une focale sur le cavalier ok donc là
elle veut tenir la pause et j'ai le cas
de bien jouer fixe suisse
lacasse g1 qui peut un jour poser
problème à le pion h un piéton mais le
pion je rage de aussi probablement
on peut faire fougères à comprendre mais
pas trop pourquoi la passe et fougères
indirects 3e 2 3 2 permettaient d'en
fermer le fou
ah oui à temps là s'il vous prend au jeu
de la cavale you do we look est bien
évidemment je suis corinne comme on dit
dans le tchat
mais c'est aussi pour content qu'ils
aient pas prenable
les finales de pions qui sont perdantes
ségala juste gagner du temps je pense
pas qu'elle va sans nul à essayer il
faut proposer nul elle a peut-être eu
raison c'est ben ouais peut-être bras
jusqu'à la gâcher elle en a même perdu
pas mal de temps sans être complètement
chat échaudé craint l'eau chaude
crasnault chaude bah je sais pas je veux
leur aide à monter des on a le droit
enfin on peut dire aussi chaque rouleau
l'ornement ça c'est pas fou oui il va du
coup pourquoi se compliquer avec des
proverbes quand on peut quand on peut le
faire en une phrase chaque rond et on
est reparti avec un double enquête aux
états leurs cette fois ci les blancs et
change pas le fou de cases blanches
on a déjà vu ça tout 4 elle joue un
genre des taux de marc auxi très bizarre
mais bon ça se joue a accueilli des
quatre arrêts ce qu'elle veut pas
prendre et faire cavalier bessin kiêu
catégorie n'est peut-être dû trouver
trois tours retour à des 1 à 3 est ce
que québec était vraiment une menace
pas sûr mais tu veux être préparés
beckham pour la paix
comment est-ce qu'on organise nos pièces
issifou trois tours a des seins ça
paraît quand même très logique
je crois ce faire les les oreilles d'âne
mais bon c'est peut-être bon ici pour
tout retour des 1 met la pression sur le
pion des six la selve on va partir pour
du tour des deux tours d un on va
doubler les le temps des heurts entre
hindous et des cas 10 secondes d'écart
est ce qu'un coup comme dame c'est un
peut être intéressant je ne crois pas
damas quatre dames à 4 ne crée aucune
menace mais se place
du coup elle revient on sait le bien pas
d'idées qui a valu aux cinq peut-être à
nul non non plutôt qu'un jeu je trouve
ouais un coup un cookie qui pose des
questions car élèves si sa longue cavale
et g4 arrive c'est être urgent 3 ici
pour détroit avec l'idée est belle la
vie et j'ai coûté 4,5 au kef au f4
kathak d'une nouvelle fois qu'il n'y a
rien à faire a vraiment du mal on sent
que l'analyse préfère ses positions
quelqu'un a des projets fous prendre ta
que l'attaqué f2 à houplines france pas
mal aussi
5 même un jour ma vie à quatre jeunes
deux allaient pousser un c'est bien
jouer des quatre cavaliers b2 et b6 pour
ricaner des cinq bien vu mais bon cahier
des cinq as peut-être foot - la turquie
par aller il faut jouer vite ici pour 4
et ab4 c'est bien joué c'est ça qui va
avoir du koweit est bien content et moi
j non mais on va se prendre à se rendre
du f 5 on va tous prendre à l'essai bien
c'est bien tout reprend des quatre noms
n'y a pas il ya la dame qui est protégé
pour le moment il n'ya rien sève est ok
allez on va donner le soccer français 5
ou besa ouais mais périlleux que ya le
fou il ya le phocéen qui restent qui
reste en prise à l'as pas vu qu'à tout
cas tu as ton prendre vous prendrez 4
qui a l'a fait le piège cep s'est tendu
les joueurs sont gagnants mais bon faut
encore finir c'est super chaud il y
avait deux entreprises se doivent de fdf
devrait hall à la fourchette
allez c'est fini voilà c'est fini cette
partie est terminée ou c'est un verre
jouer
avait très bien joué et en 2d c'est pas
de la merde ouais là mon avis n'a aucune
chance de rater ça une fois pas dans
quel monde
les hackers un tour de france a bien le
temps à battre est fou j'ai deux
peut-être aller on défend bien je la
vends prise voilà difficile alors il
reste combien de temps j'ai pas le gpat
anduze et été chauds mais combien
combien il ya 13 12 et on n'a pas le
temps et on n'a pas le temps qu'il reste
où son coach comme chasse commence sur 4
minutes 41
c'est du favoritisme ne met pas le temps
ouais on met pas le temps mais pas le
temps c'est ailleurs qu'il reste deux
parties seb de 4040 ces deux parties ok
allez vous tenir que tu est une petite
nul c'est une balle de match
c'est une balle de match à mon avis ça
ben may de match baal et blanc sont
blancs sont déjà très bien ils ont guère
conserver le pion c5
bon c'est toujours tendu ses positions
mais lecavalier en décote énorme d'une
classe par ressemble tout fou j'ai sept
jours plus tard les deux pays six
rapidement ouais mais bécistes aura
toujours opus c6 qui peut traîner
quelques mois le veut qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle va avoir cinq bons on a essayé
de faire grave on va prendre le temps
alors prendre le temps et comment parce
que le pur arrivants 1,5 c jouer et
maintenant des irrigants déçu mais il ya
ces trois ans leur ajouter 6 ou des
sites non mais non c'est un bien joué
c'est un bien joué elle protège le prêt
par cas et 6 passes et si c'est
difficile
elle voulait conserver le pion elle
matérialise par gavage rien laissé un
couple qui a peut-être des idées crise
est cadrée mais trop de temps ma grande
il ya peut-être du t2 four b3 ou des
trucs comme ça aussi attention ouais la
sensation je donne des deux obligés
d'amener cette phase iii j'aime bien la
position est assez compliquée la seb tu
reprends ici
attendu je pense que les noirs sont bien
en pratique dans ses positions qu'ils
pensent je préfère avec les blancs mais
bon avec le peu de temps la plaque qui
pourrait nous mais j'aime bien la tient
bien
non mais j'aime bien mon petit pion plus
en ces cinq là j'aime bien le temps
alors comment est ce qu'on continue à me
4.922 ce qu'il va y avoir un truc avec
roy g73 g6 pour protéger le pion et
après genre damage quatre fous des 5 à 4
j'aime bien aller à carcassonne saison à
l'étranger s'ils s'imaginent ça nous en
donne jasmin qui tu pense pas je pense
qu'ils vont jouer vite surtout là c'est
trop long ce qu'elle fait allez faut un
peu plus de conviction côté noir
allez allez le temps h5 ali va se jouer
il faut peut-être wade à mach 4 j'ai
envie de voir du damage 4 depuis tout à
l'heure et g4 j'y crois j'y crois pas
j'y crois pas dit qu'on peut pour le
blond âgé 4 direct à l'april pion de
trois cavaliers pros f60
j'en sais rien je ne sais pas ce qui se
tend de ton détroit qui est toujours
mais il ya la magie de moi peut-être
réseau t3f 2 1 c'est quoi la crèche où
il ya du chip où partout il y en a dans
tous les sens
il ya peut-être du tour pro f 3 4 1 3 2
3 4 ça me paraît super héros à l'été des
4 points chicanes qui a régalé ses six
il faut juste un oui il faut envoyer
vrai c'est chose faite
écoliers h 14 il est 20 h 4
le problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de
jeu et y appelle la grande sa valise et
malheureusement c'est pas s'est pas fait
c'est là encore c'est pas fait qu'ils
avaient des cinq toiles sporting
doublait mettre au point un an ce marché
correspond à restaurer forman ans qui
gagne mais le voit pas normalement
elle voit pas c'est incroyable
d'ailleurs quel bois elle ne voit pas
pour redonner sa d'organiser ça gagne
aussi parce que puis on prend et de
pions
et ben voilà la dernière c'est la
dernière hu de monde on y arrive et seb
c'est la dernière c'est l'aval de match
balle de match pour les deux joueuses
ah ah c'est beau c'est aller à leur mini
on espère on espère être là c'est à ce
moment là du match à égalité les deux
choses c'est vraiment le même niveau
d'investissement de l'abbé six et cinq
peut-être non qu'elle s'est développée
c'est pas mal comment on fait des procès
kahn at on essaye elle fait fausse
adresse qu est-ce qu on rendra
finalement c'est ça inquiète dame tombée
trois prises robe marron ok elle attend
de faire tourner ces 8es de tenir
largement le plan normalement cavaliers
des deux qui avait les baies 3 cavaliers
à 5 avec 9.4 va le faire l'attaqué
bessette
alors il ya deux écoles soit en russie a
joué cinq rapidement d'ailleurs au
rendez vous dès 8 vous prend à cinq et
on va préparer ou cinq doit essayer en
tout cas très bien joué cavalier à ça
qu'il faut le faire
oui ah oui tu connais tu la tour ont
cessé de mettre la tour ans et set
j'aurais fait exactement la même chose
et aura plus de mal à jeux sont waimes
étape at on n'a pas besoin pour faire un
nul à ok d'accord tu peux juste à siran
cannes où il se passe quoi il ya un gros
match
je crois comme canule il ya une 5 + 1
une 3 + 1 et une heure un plus un
bassiste obama mais je crois qu'ici les
noirs sont mieux c'est parce que tu
voudrais pouvoir jouer pour eux 5 oui
d'accord elle a bien joué il a joué
juste un petit peu mieux j'en ai déjà
perdu des comme ça contre des grands
maîtres boom et à des sacrifices des
fois en 17 ans a laissé ses joueurs de
pipeau c'est du pipeau c'est un peu
mieux pour les noirs après ça doit ça
doit se tenir et katia une nouvelle fois
elle sait pas quoi faire elle prend trop
de temps
seb à mon avis ça peut ça peut tourner
côté arménien 7,7 final le solde d'un
jeu kébé 3 à la lucidité de ramener le
cavalier en fait le cavaliere à 5 à un
moment donné il sert absolument plus
large et 4 2 c'est bien n'a pas peur à
lagos non non non là elle est dans son
élément droit est celui qu'il faut jouer
comme le 30 sept
d'ailleurs c'est très beau mais ici les
jeux ne sont pas toujours au courant du
fait que ce soit la dernière partie les
fratries chose qu'à valider
détroit reuze attention nous attaquer
mais ce carillon v6 est mal placée au
final c'est bon mais bien sûr national
de tours ashram ça a beaucoup de
beaucoup de cran et la menace qu'elle
allait détrôner
alors est ce que les blancs vont jouer
h3 pour s'en prendre aux pignons et je
vais changer poser une question aux
manettes pour se croire trop c'est bon
qu'est-ce qu'elle pose comme question
réalité cavaliers prend elle est obligée
de reprendre du cavalier et pas toujours
selon h trois mois je crois peut-être
qu'elle est contente de d'échanger un
peu peut-être tout rejet alentours 5 y
avait eu 4 j'ai l'impression que les
blancs sont très mal ici ok pour
peut-être réussir à faire qu'il s'est
vite et à qui vous savez et c'est pas
possible
allez mes joues plus vite là ça va ça va
se jouer à rien c'est peut-être pour g3
ton nom ton g3 qui a valu au 4-3-3 je
sais par eux de allez à là elle a trouvé
un goût tour h 2 attention aux cavaliers
17 et chacun qui peuvent rodez 2
peut-être elle veut le faire à
j'essaie de tourcoing 6 3 ans de cavale
et ses huit qui a aidé 6 peut être ici
est intéressant menace turque font des
médailles à elle perd le nom ça va
décoiffer 4.2 4.9 6 même si sa part de
tous les coins beckett et les problèmes
c'est souffrent et tourcoing b2
attention le match mais ça vaille à
tours 8
alors à temps non c'est bien je trouve
que c'est bien fait pour eux c'est à toi
mais chaque et tours 8e tour 5e pris 0,6
et on envoie à aller on voit alors ça
c'est complètement fini je pense c'est
non non non je pense pas je pense pas ok
mais roger cap d'un jeu ouais mais le
roi va venir en rêve 7 ou un f6 et le
pion blanc peu plus poussé je pense que
c'est complètement fini mais j'en suis
pas sûr qu'elle veut gagner un peu de
temps non mais c'est très chaud en 3
secondes
ouais concernés non non non non non non
mais vous faites tu dois les noirs et
noir ont gagné il ya plus de temps pour
les blancs les noirs ont gagné sept
tours prend à 2 attention au registre
oui ça va se finir ça va se finir sur
cette plongée cette tournée elle va
tomber tension mais elle est tombée
c'est fini c'est fini c'est ben c'est
gagné danielian qui a gâché par match
bravo de regarder d'écouter ouest à
grasse rendre compte que le match et
fille qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
fini
victoire de la joueuse armenian seb des
deux elles savent pas en tout cas elle a
le triomphe modeste
joli match un beau match très beau mais
franchement super super content de la
tournure de mer dessus oui c'était
c'était au suspense assez joué à la
dernière partie c'est exactement ce
qu'on souhaitait voir dans ce scénario
parfait scénario parfait et finalement
ça s'est joué seb dans les positions
calme ce match ouais bah c'est bien ça
montre qu'il n'ya pas que de l'agression
on peut manoeuvrer un petit peu et qu'il
faut bien absente six finales mais katia
qui a jamais la dernière partie
finalement elle reflète le match
moi je suis d'accord même si elle n'a
pas été dans le ton du match le mans et
bien c'était c'est envoyer plus quand
même c'était plus tendu
la plupart des partis nous c'était des
petite finale qui se jouait à la
manoeuvre
37 ouais mais dans un jeu dire dans
l'esprit cette histoire de un moment
donné ou katia dans la position elle a
plus de plan fait à la manquer de plans
elle a manqué d'idées ça c'est vrai
c'est une constante sur le match et du
coup elle va se passer en demi-finale
elle va rencontrer la gagnante du match
on trouve marie et ouais et ça va pas
être un cadeau danielian ça va pas être
un cadeau allait quand même solide
elle joue très bien les positions type
slave karo kann donc
ça va s'amener c'est pas un cadeau que
ce soit pour marie ou pour harry qu'à
voir laquelle des deux se qualifiera ça
ce sera le 30 sept lequel ce match là et
le 31 on commentera avec maxime vachier
lagrave le manager willi prague amanda
ça c'est pas mal je sais pas si tu
suivras agit c'est peu probable vu c'est
pas contre vous mais je vais avoir du
mal à me trotter cup
ouais un peu de boulot un peu de repos
tous à mon avis les commentaires de
maxime vachier lagrave ça vaudra son
pesant de cacahuètes quand même
j'aimerais bien de voix en commentateur
sportif c'est à dire un peu plus de
trois heures donc il y aura l'occasion
de le voir en mode
explicateur est en mode supporter à
supporter de l'ol alors est ce qu'on
prend deux trois questions avant de
partir qu'est-ce qu'on les écrits
maintenant que caterina est sorti
laquelle est la plus jolie qui reste je
veux pas tout en acoustique pas mal
kosteniuk année le championnat qui est
super d'apprendre cette nouvelle je
crois qu'il est content du commentaire
de maxime est ce que il ya eric il
demande quand est ce qu'on te revois
c'est bah écoute on
va essayer de te revoir bientôt ben on
me revois con tu décides c'est pas tout
à fait moi qui fais je me décide mais
n'hésitez pas à écrire si vous voulez
revoir seb n'hésitez pas à ce qu'on a
fait hier ils voulaient faire des
messages à daniel rêve que j'ai une
augmentation quand je commente seul et
du cou n'hésitez pas à écrire à daniel
pour oi sam copeland pour leur dire que
c'était bien les commentaires excède
avec ses bois histoire qui me
soutiennent qu'en jeu quand je note les
noms de qui commandent quoi jusqu'au
manche et avec qui je donne les noms
mais en dernier recours c'est pas
vraiment moi qui décide en réalité donc
et on aura ouais mais peut-être
peut-être aussi pour les grands prix et
tout y aura tellement une masse de
choses a commenté que on va faire plein
de trucs
est ce que je savais ce qu'est ce que tu
vas revenir serait bien ça de refaire ça
des parties pédagogique contre la
communauté est ce que tu veux les
pédagogies fier ouais j'avais fait ça il
ya un petit moment et c'était pas mal
les pédagogies fier ok bah tu me dis
c'est un peu chaud les prochains jours
mais bah quand tu seras revenu de de
slovénie de slovénie tu reviens encore
je reviens le meurtre 10 5 juin mercredi
5 mai en plus ça tu si tu sais pas tu
t'es intituté peut-être pas inscrits
mais il va y avoir un truc fantastique
là en juin
c'est le jeu des qualifs du championnat
du monde de 960 en dise plus de ce sera
sur czech com en partenariat avec la
fidh d'après ce que j'ai compris et du
beau monde
ouais et en plus ce que j'aime bien
c'est que l'inscription est payante eux
mêmes si c'est pas grand chose je me dis
que ça peut un peu éloigné les castors
les castors
mais les gens qui cède avec un
ordinateur j'appelle ça des castors non
eh ben tu crois dans ce genre parce que
patrice baï à un prix si tu te qualifies
mais dans le sens où si tu te fais
choper là tu as payé taper avec ta carte
bleue c'est ultra pas anonyme je me dis
que même si un peu du castor ça éloigne
quand même
une grosse partie donc façon va pas se
qualifier on va pas on va pas battre
magnus un tu vois ce que je veux dire
non non mais ça te permet d'avoir un
tournant plus faire où tu peux te plus
juste où tu peux jouer contre des mecs
de haut niveau se trouve ça intéressant
et la cadence 10 + 2 c'est une cadence
intermédiaires se laisse un peu le temps
de s'habituer à la pause
ouais bah voila moi je suis enfin toute
façon je vais y participer c'est sûr
mais mais c'est plus pour le délire de
jouer le 960 serrar qui détrônera fort
en 960 donc c'est intéressant je trouve
une question est ce que game center le
livre que l'on peut trouver en france et
je crois pas mais il est dur à lien en
anglais il ya quand même pas mal de
textes dont il faut avoir un peu de
vocabulaire mais franchement ça va en
tout cas ça vous vraiment c'est un super
boulot
toi tu parle bien anglais c'est ben
ouais déjà courant pas bilingue complet
mais tu es à l'aise à l'aise tu es à
l'aise et dont club nous dit qu'elle
avait six chat qui revient autour d'elle
pendant le match c'est vrai que ça n'est
pas forcément un quatre gamins c'est
beaucoup et ceux qui lui disaient les
goûts ouais les castors à les castors du
coup mais ouais c'est pas évident en
tout cas j'espère que ça ça lui a donné
des indications sur sa forme pour le
tour un des candidats qui doit être
quand même son objectif numéro 1 de
l'année
tu dis que ça commence la semaine
prochaine ça oui et c'est pour défier
qui joue bandjoun oui c'est pour des
faits joignent je ne le crois pas parce
qu'elle avait battue 4-1 en finale
si je me rappelle ma wii wheel que je
stream vrai pour les qualifs de 960
ouais bien sûr bien sûr on va rigoler je
n'ai pas la prétention de devenir
champion du monde de 960 ça va tu vas
jouer du stream ouais on dit en vrai et
l'ina avec plus d'expérience et
l'habitude de la soie les favorites
n'ont bhavan en 24/7 est favorite
et quand même dans les cinq que la
meilleure joueuse du moment c'est pour
moi c'était une vraie surprise de voir
là elle a eu beau un bon niveau
ça a été un peu comment dire pas très
homogène mais elle a montré que quand
elle voulait elle avait de beaux restes
ici et non non elle a vraiment elle a
vraiment elle a vraiment sorti un beau
match est serré stratégiquement je pense
que katia elle aurait peut-être dû
essayé de la prendre plus à la gorge
alors je sais pas exactement comment
peut-être mais peut-être joué un peu
prendre un peu plus de risque y est allé
un peu plus franco sur le roi qui ne
sais pas je restructure karo kann tu
fais un truc à recomposer tu as le droit
de retrait a bien défendu comme il ya eu
deux parties où elle s'était attaqué à
trouver des solutions
et puis comme dit l'expression chakra
l'eau donc partant de la moncelle il est
temps de de ce kit est oui je mets une
petite pub de sortie de stream et voilà
c'est tout vacheresse conclure en fait
voiture jeu et bien bravo aux 2
c'était super sympa j'ai adoré faire ça
commenter ce match qui était très serré
et je suis chaud pour une prochaine
quand vous voulez sur ce format là c'est
très intéressant et veut dire que tout
le monde voit lapin pour ce que vous
faites
soyez heureux et pas très bien le
message positif
[Musique]